Jamie,
you.
Oh Philip the Franco.
Alright,
I'm good man.
It's cracking.
I'm good.
Although all the conversation we had
right before to be the good stuff and
then all of this could be two hours of
bad.
Yeah.
We shit on some movies and got,
got mad about Republicans and talking
and then we gotten mad about Democrats.
And you're putting.
You're putting away in an I statement.
Yep.
That was us.
I was just,
I was just being your therapist man.
Thanks dude.
Sweet.
So sweet of you.
Isn't that what a podcast is?
Just like,
let me,
let me hear what you're saying,
but then let me,
let me talk about the world in a way.
Yeah.
Is that a phone?
That's a tiny little tiny one man.
But you get the little tiny iphone.
Yeah.
This is.
This is for my daily example of why I
need to be patient.
I had an iphone six plus the biggest
storage I was.
I was really happy with it and I was
like,
man,
I need to get that iphone seven.
And the only one they had was the small
one with the smallest storage and it's,
it's a piece of garbage,
you know?
I know.
Well just because I'm like,
you know,
I don't need that much storage,
I'll use the cloud,
but I don't because I don't trust the
cloud.
So I cared of all those Dick Pics,
getting all the Dick pics kegs of them.
I think that's the good thing about not
being extraordinary in any way.
I'm not doing that.
Like you don't have to worry about your
dirt.
No one needs to see it.
So you just ran out of,
what is it like a 32 gigabyte or
something?
Yeah.
No,
it's like I have to.
I'm like,
which memory will I delete before I
make.
It makes me be a little bit selective,
but I don't know.
In this day and age of stupid,
does it bother you that it's small?
Not as much,
but you get used to it,
right?
What do you have?
Yeah,
I have the seven plus man.
Do you use that?
When you look at websites in particular
where you don't have to expand the
screen to get the entire thing,
you don't have to go back and forth to
get the entire article and there's
little tricks that people don't know
where it's like you just double tap,
not pushing,
but double tap and like all that shit
that's on the top of the screen that
comes down for you [inaudible].
They just use it for people with tiny
hands.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
The if you double tap the home button,
right.
This stuff,
that stuff they made for people that
just aren't.
They don't fit like the standard and you
just,
you just use them and then fucking
buzzfeed calls it life hacks.
Then like 10 things you didn't know,
like let's go,
let's get 7 million people's office.
Some basic shit there.
There was that one phone that they had.
I guess it was the iphone four that had
the sharper edges on the side.
It was very narrow.
That's the perfect size phone for
texting.
You think so?
Yeah.
It just fits in your hand.
Perfect.
Like it locks in place.
Like I can text with one hand with this
thing,
but
not that easy.
It's a little slippery.
You just got to switch to get like that
swipey keyboard.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I've seen people do that.
Bryan county that did it makes you
angry?
No,
it doesn't make me angry,
but my friend Brian Cowen was trying to
show me how good it was.
Like,
look,
I right.
I just go from here to here and he
fucked it up a few times.
I'm like,
go fuck off.
Just to just from this five minutes of
before and after.
It's like I hate swipey keyboards and
movies where kids have cancer to things
I won't stand for.
They're pulling on your heartstrings and
if they show you cancer and a kid has
cancer,
like right away,
like,
look,
you could have made me sad in a less
brutal way.
So are you okay?
If in the trailer they let you know the
kid has cancer,
fucking stupid.
I see what they're doing.
It's like kid out of here and you were
talking about arrival.
I didn't even watch the movie.
I watched the movie for three minutes,
the girl had cancer and I'm like,
fuck you,
and I hung it up.
I'm going to sleep.
I'm not going to watch this.
He's going to want to go on this
depressing journey right before bed.
It's going to get me fucked up.
Dreams,
so uninterested in depressing movies.
I know.
I've read the news.
I watch television.
I pay attention to internet videos from
all over the world of depressing shit.
I know it's real.
I think the moment I had my first kid,
I was like,
okay,
this is.
This is my realization that at any point
I could have the most damaging pain in
the world,
so I get that I don't need.
I don't need to be depressed and
reminded of that at every moment.
[inaudible].
That's what I'm constantly thinking
about when I'm not having a happy
moment.
I'm like,
how?
How could the world completely fuck up
my whole being?
Yeah.
I'm more interested in funny things
these days or really stupid horror
movies.
Is that just escapism from the insanity
that we're dealing with?
Yeah,
that's all it is.
It's all escapism.
I mean,
even game of thrones or House of cards,
which is like about politics.
So total escapism.
These are not real people.
Yeah.
But I,
that's what I ended up finding is I end
up rooting for people that normally
wouldn't root for it.
Right.
So in house of cards,
I'm totally rooting for them and
breaking bad.
Even the final season when he's doing
all that fucked up stuff,
I'm like,
yeah,
well too white.
I'm with you man.
I didn't watch the final season.
I didn't get that far.
But uh,
I'm in the middle of a season three
right now of house of cards and yeah,
Kevin Spacey's goddamned murderer.
I'm trying to remember if third,
if the third season is kind of like the
man season before,
because last season the last season was
amazing.
What is it like how they have five out
for is for?
So three I think was kind of just felt
like a setup season.
I'm and through them,
man.
I'm fucking cooking through them.
Watching a four or five a week.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you,
if you haven't started that episode one
of season two,
that's where I was like,
okay,
I'm in this is because I feel like you
always have to have that one episode
where you don't know what's gonna happen
where you're like,
okay,
I'm on,
I'm on fucking shaky ground.
This isn't something that I'm going to
watch while I'm cooking dinner and not
really paying attention and not miss
anything out.
Right.
That's like,
that's like scandal.
You're like,
okay,
they're going to go on some like fucking
eight minute monologue where it's like
you can't do blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then he was like,
what happened?
Okay,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever bullshit.
Well,
escapism is.
I mean it's fun.
It's.
But after awhile you just run it.
It runs its course.
I think just absorbing media,
just taking
in too much.
After a while you just get extremely
jaded.
You know,
like I've seen people that are tweeting
about things online and you go,
God,
that guy's fucking jaded man.
Like people are so jaded.
And they realized like the amount of
information,
the amount of data that people are
getting on a daily basis,
it's just you're not designed for this.
Yeah,
no one's designed have unlimited options
for entertainment viewing at your
disposal on demand all the time.
If you ever want to like a quick
reminder of how add and how true that
is.
Just look at your fucking not you
specifically,
but your own twitter history.
I'll go from talking about something
like that.
Deeply political and I'm like this
fucking craziness to like did you see
tonight's episode?
And there's like a difference of five
minutes.
Exactly.
Everything's always
happening and I just,
I don't get it.
I'm critical of it,
but
I'm part of it,
you know,
well we're,
we're,
we're definitely changing in our
attention span is changing and probably
not for the better.
And we're,
we're,
we're accustomed to things being quick
and rapid.
Like here's a perfect example.
The way you guys edit your videos.
You don't have any pauses.
You're not human in your video.
That is because I got like a c minus in
public speaking.
Everybody does it.
Everybody on Youtube does it.
They all do that thing where they take
out all the ums and pauses and they go
from one thing to level a little bit,
a little bit,
a little,
a little bit because it is,
it is
battle of attention and battle of eyes.
But I think that I think people are
seeing more and more,
especially even the youtube,
the Youtube Algorithm podcast,
I think that there is 100 percent always
going to be an audience for longer form
things.
Uh,
my video is started out as it was even
in the little intro sequence.
It started out as three to four minutes.
Let me talk about the world for three or
four minutes.
My videos now are 10 to 18 minutes every
day.
Granted a lot more is happening every
day and they're like this,
this new new presidency and,
and stuff like that.
But there is an audience that wants
more.
And so you had the vine guys,
but even,
I mean finds dead now.
But those guys have now launched into
longer form pieces where some of it is
three to four and then some are daily,
10 to 18 minute pieces,
so I think there's always going to be an
audience.
People are tuning in longer,
more than ever because the Internet was
tuned in for for six seconds,
15 seconds,
one minute,
three to four,
and it's just getting longer and longer,
but it's not even just the longer
longer.
Even if you do a three minute thing,
you're still going to edit out all those
little tiny gaps in between sentences.
Yeah.
What's that about?
It's just getting out as much.
If I didn't,
if I.
If I stopped cutting out my pause,
my video is five minutes longer.
It'd be.
It'd be a nightmare.
Really?
Yeah.
Because my video is I don't,
I don't script.
I'm not reading from everyone else or
from something.
Someone else wrote A.
I do all my own research.
It's me taking all the information and
then just going on this,
this word soup rambly thing for for five
minutes to make a three minute piece.
Do you like you take in too much data
because you're doing all this,
you have,
you have to have to have the main
difference between,
I think the last time I came on here,
which was about two years ago and now is
back then I was,
I was Kinda scared to share my opinion,
right?
So I would just,
I would kind of reputation of reddit
stories that popped up and things that
popped up on websites of like distinct
happened.
Anyway,
here's the next thing that happened.
So you're more of an aggregator of
things that have happened like I was
then and now it's more of because no one
trusts anything,
right?
Where we talk about right wing or left
wing people being in their own bubbles
and you know,
we go in like I know I know the truth,
but you might not because you're just
sticking to the stuff that,
that,
that you believe in.
And then you see something from an
outside source and go,
well that's bullshit.
That's not buzzfeed.
Right.
Well and,
and that's,
and that's the problem.
I mean,
buzzfeed really,
in my opinion,
fuck themselves with the way that they
released those documents.
I couldn't be completely confirmed right
with the whole,
like trump and the,
uh,
the prostitutes peeing on the bed stuff
and they're like,
we can't,
we can't confirm it and neither can any
of the other places that have gotten
this information can't confirm it.
But there is this piece of paper that
says that it may have happened.
What's even worse is all of these
mainstream news sources.
We're doing it.
We're all releasing this story,
the salacious details on the story of
Donald Trump and the Russian
prostitutes,
water sports.
Like,
what the Fuck Outta here.
Just a way it read.
I immediately called bullshit.
I'm like,
do you really think that he has people
pee on him?
People pee on the bed and he wants them
to pee on the bed and he watches like,
fuck off.
So that's the problem,
right?
Is that's not even the actual thing that
the story was,
but that's what it turned into the whole
story.
And ended up being.
Or like we're supposed to be that Barack
Obama and Michelle Obama stayed in a
hotel room.
Right.
He hated them so much that he hired to
come and pee on the bed,
not on him.
Right.
And so that.
But yeah,
but then everyone made it like,
Oh,
he likes pee on his face.
And it was like.
And it became this example of,
as long as it's hilarious enough,
I forget who said it,
as long as it's hilarious and enough
people will just roll with it.
But it's so hack.
It's not even hilarious.
And it's like,
that's like what a hack premise writer
would write.
Like if you want to write a hack story,
a hack scene in a movie,
but a crazy person.
He hires all these ogres baby.
Come on,
pee on Daddy.
You know,
it's like,
it's so stupid.
I feel like if you,
if you heard that though and you were
like,
oh,
it's like a coke fueled businessman from
the eighties.
He be like,
yeah,
that probably happened,
but not in today's world.
Well,
not only that,
you don't think Donald Trump would check
his hotel room for cameras.
Oh really?
Do you don't think that a
multibillionaire who's kind of a freak
would go into that thing and have
someone scrubbed the room and may have
some expert?
Yeah,
man,
he's probably super paranoid.
He's fucked over so many people.
Maybe that's why we don't see the tax
returns.
He's paying all these people off.
Exactly.
The tax return thing is real.
Does that bother you?
So yes,
I know that bothers a lot of people.
Well,
it should.
I think,
you know what?
I think it's,
it's,
it's easy to argue that,
you know,
well,
people aren't going to be able to
understand it,
but I also know so where people are
going to go,
well it's going to be misconstrued,
but it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's an honest question.
You heard that argument?
Yes.
That's going to be.
Taxes are going to be misconstrued.
Yeah.
They're gonna.
They're gonna take the smallest things
and they're going to on TV and the media
does at times and they're gonna.
They're gonna.
Expand on it and make it this crazy
thing.
The same example with the urination
story.
All of a sudden I looked at facebook,
all my real story,
right?
But it started out as a core thing.
Right?
But he plays for this and then it turned
into Donald trump likes getting peed on.
I understand what you're saying,
but the problem is the taxes are an
actual real thing.
100 tax returns.
It's very clear and concise,
right?
I mean,
so they're going to say,
well look at this money.
It could have been all these things and
then it's not.
It could be.
It is,
right?
That's an argument.
It's not one that I agree with,
but I would prefer to actually see
because I am a big fan of like get as
much information out as possible so that
we can actually break shit down.
Well,
every single president has done it,
right.
That's what's so unprecedented about it.
And he has multiple business ties
apparently with Russia and he owes a
shitload of money to China.
Like those things are massive factors
and he has these business ventures that
he has an all these countries all over
the world.
What's really crazy is his son's running
his business now.
Right?
So his sons are getting flown around
with secret service details all on the
country's dime.
He spending more money on travel in
seven months and Obama did in eight
years.
That's the projection.
If things go really?
Yes.
Okay.
I'd have to.
I'd have to look at the numbers so you
can find it,
Jamie,
because that's for me,
that's like New York Times.
I'm pretty sure because that's.
For me,
that's,
that's the whole premise of my show now
is you're making that argument of why we
should.
I then on my show mentioned that
argument.
I then go into the argument of how it
could be misconstrued and then I
separately give my opinion,
which I personally believe that we
should get the tax,
but it's not even an opinion thing.
It's law.
He supposed to release his tax returns.
That's what your supposed to do,
but don't you remember there's the whole
audit audit which will go on to the end
of time and none of it makes any sense.
I mean how long does the audit last
year?
Who's auditing it?
Right.
And then the hard thing is the story.
There's like eight stories every day.
Um,
I feel like because I haven't seen
Kellyanne Conway on TV as much lately,
it's,
it's less of the case and there was
even,
it felt like two days were Donald Trump
didn't tweet,
which was unprecedented.
Uh,
but it's,
it's overloading your [inaudible] there.
There are a lot of people that will ask
me why didn't you cover a certain story?
And it's just,
I am one guy making at that time a 16
minute show that I'm trying to explain
things properly.
So how am I going to,
how am I going to get a point?
Get across all the points?
Yeah.
Look at this in Forbes,
trump's family cost his trips to costco
taxpayers nearly as much in a month as
Obama's in a whole year.
Yeah,
it's,
it's the whole thing is very bizarre.
And what's really crazy is he was very
critical of Obama President Barack
Obama's vacation.
It's costing tax payers millions of
dollars.
Unbelievable.
What about you?
Hey man,
but he's going to be.
You have to think about the net.
You're going to save all that money from
all the fewer regulations.
Right?
Something,
something we're not saving any money
from,
fewer regulations,
we're going to have to clean all those
ducks that get covered in oil.
The whole thing is so fucked,
fucked.
It's hard.
I mean,
but even like you're throwing out your
opinions now and I think that it's
important to have those people,
but I think it's also then important to
take the time to look into where the Fox
News,
the Breitbarts,
the Donald,
the,
all those places where they're coming
from as far as where their opinions come
from because I don't think so.
Salon.com.
Rolfing didn't post.
I mean we've got to echo chambers on the
left and on the right and it's the sound
of the both of them is definitely to the
point where you can't make out what the
fuck is going on.
Right.
And I think that's why it's important to
look at both so you can kind of fucking
like Shimmy it through a filter and see
where these sources are coming from.
Gold looking for gold man.
Looking for the fucking truth.
Because who knows what the fuck it is.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
It doesn't exist for people,
right?
It's reality.
I mean,
it's been a conversation of like reality
doesn't matter,
right?
It's all about perception.
That is,
that is more true than ever today,
right?
Because people believe people believe in
their right or left wing thing like they
believe in God,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's not just a fact to them,
it's not just opinion,
it is ingrained belief and it's.
And it's just me trying not to close the
door on anyone so that I can always try
and have someone's ear.
Right.
So people can think that.
What do you mean by that?
So depending on the video.
Right.
So yesterday I talked about it
personally,
is that you're saying,
okay,
yes,
yes.
So yesterday I talked about,
uh,
the police officer or the off duty cop
and Anaheim.
Oh,
I saw that.
I was crazy.
It was crazy.
And my whole thing was playing it for
people that don't know what we're
talking about.
Okay.
So there's some stuff that we don't see.
There's two arguments.
Uh,
there is one that,
uh,
the off duty cop will,
we'll go through his story first.
He said that these kids were walking on
his,
uh,
his property walk through his property.
Maybe they're cutting through.
Um,
he said something to the girl.
The boy says that you called her a
contract.
I said,
that's not appropriate.
Um,
and he says,
uh,
the child's didn't say that.
He said that he was willing to shoot the
off duty cop.
He said,
I'm going to shoot you.
The boy says no.
I said,
I'm going to sue you,
but the cop says he's going to detain
the kid until the police arrive because
you threatened an off duty police
officer.
Right?
That then turns into this.
This kid he like pushes the police
officer,
another kid,
a different cable.
So that happens at first.
Uh,
the kid that's being detained pushes the
police.
Uh,
the off duty cop into a bush.
Then two minutes past,
uh,
they slowly get closer to this hedge.
Um,
another,
another kid puts hands on the off duty
cop,
another kid.
Then shoulder checks the cop over the
hedge.
Then the kid who originally did that
touch them.
God,
it'd be so much easier to have the
video.
Then one of the other kids who would put
hands on him,
punched the cop,
another kid jumped over the hedge and
they kind of surrounded him.
And at that point,
uh,
the cop pulled out a gun,
um,
and everyone kind of ran away and then
it looks like the cops trying to pull
the kid over the hedge while holding the
gun,
it goes off.
And then two kids arrested.
He's not right.
And it's a crazy video.
And so we're talking about a story like
that that,
that becomes a little different than
just talking about politics because it's
seeing something not knowing fully how
it started.
Right?
So you're having to take the word of to
people without having the evidence and
trying to get across the point.
My pain,
my main points in the video,
um,
I don't like that.
The cop didn't seem to deescalate the
situation,
didn't continually announced that he was
a police officer,
didn't announce that he was denouncing
it at all.
So there's this point in the video where
a kid I believe says,
I don't believe you're a cop or how do I
know you're a cop or something like
that.
Um,
there's two different videos,
so it seems like maybe he announced it,
but if I was him,
right,
this is hindsight,
of course I'd be constantly announcing
that I am an off duty police officer and
I'm detaining this kid until the police
show up rather than potentially just
some stranger grabbing a child and also,
um,
I don't agree.
Or I,
if I was in his position and all of a
sudden I started being attacked,
I would 100 percent have pulled the gun
out,
but I wouldn't have fired it because
they were already running away.
And I think that is
attacking him because the way he was
handling the situation.
Totally.
And that's,
that's a hard thing of I have my
personal opinion in these segmented
areas.
I think he could have done way more to
deescalate the situation.
Um,
I think that when he pulled out the gun,
he had a choice to either fix his hands
so that he didn't accidentally shoot a
gun around children.
Why does he have a round chambered?
Right?
Why is the safety not on?
Those are important questions,
right?
So you have to,
especially someone that has a concealed
weapon,
someone that's an off duty cop,
you have to hold them to a higher
standard.
My argument there though is if I was in
that same position,
I would have 100 percent as I was being
attacked,
especially if I have a weapon on me that
all of a sudden I'm going to get worried
that maybe it could be used against me
as these kids are already attacked me.
I would pull it out,
but then he takes it to a different
right level
where even the way he pulled it out,
he pulled it out slow and sloppy,
right?
Like if I saw someone reaching under
their shirt like that for a gun,
if I was a crazy person,
I would totally attacked him,
tackle them 100 percent.
If they don't get ahold of that gun,
then they're not armed.
As soon as they get ahold of that gun,
there aren't.
Right.
I mean,
if he's doing all this jazz and reaching
in and it's taken so much time,
that's all the time you can punch him in
the face like this.
He's not going to stop you from punching
in.
The face of it is reaching and grabbing
his guns slow and sloppy.
It took a long time because he was doing
it with one hand,
lifting up his shirt was trying to get
the gun.
Yeah.
I think he was posturing a lot of ways
to like letting the.
Oh Yeah,
oh yeah,
look at this.
Look at ditch dare has been garden.
Now what the the press conference
afterwards.
It feels very much like they're.
They're getting their,
their ducks in a row before they really
come down on them of course,
but a cop is just a person so there's
going to be great cops and there's going
to be morons and there's going to be
people that just didn't realize the
situation was going to get to where it
got to and they just didn't handle all
the steps along the way and that's
probably what happened with him.
He probably thought he was going to say,
Hey,
stop coming through my lawn and making
noise.
You will fucks,
you know,
and the kids like,
fuck you,
I'll shoot you.
And he's like,
Oh really?
Motherfuck Aroma Cup,
you don't believe me?
God dammit,
look at this.
This is my fucking.
But so like talking about that story,
it's trying to take in both sides of the
argument and then separately giving my
opinion and I did an event last night
and a kid said,
you know,
what do you,
what do you say to people that disagree
with you there?
Especially from the Latino community,
right?
Where things like how a cop is going to
treat me is going to be different than
how they treat us,
and I said,
I think it's 100 percent fine for you to
have a disagreement.
Tell me.
Talk to me.
Don't,
don't look at my opinion and go,
this is a fucking asshole.
I hate this fucking guy.
Michael trade talks about in the special
where he had he went through like a
weird thing to try and educate me.
Give me your point of view and that's
why it's okay for people to go like he.
He tried to give both both sides.
He gave his opinion.
Who?
Who is he though?
Were you saying?
Just people.
People out.
People that watch my show,
right?
Because I have far left far right.
People that watch,
they don't always agree,
but they know that I'm always going into
it with the best of intentions and I'm
not going to hide facts and I'm not
gonna Hide my opinion and I think that's
important.
Yeah.
Well,
when you're seeing a video like that,
you're not seeing what had transpired
before.
It got to the point where he's holding
onto that kid.
Right?
So who knows who was a dick.
He didn't handle it well,
but you don't expect the kids to him
well because your fucking kids.
No kid handles anything.
Well,
what name me a 10 year old kid who deals
with things.
Well,
you know,
they didn't.
They're just trying things out there,
experimenting.
They really don't know how to
communicate properly.
I think the number one thing people in
their 20 to says I was such a stupid kid
and then then,
then you go to the thirties and I was
uh,
when I was 20,
I was such a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
And it just keeps going.
You hope that you're growing.
Yeah.
When I was 30 I was retarded GRANDPA.
No,
I'm telling you.
Didn't you see that Salon Dot com
article?
You can say that.
You can definitely still say it.
I remember we talked about that last
time I called.
I didn't,
I didn't try and take back that word.
I just want to be able to say I just
wanna be able to say kill yourself.
Just get you definitely saw that.
Yeah,
and because we say,
well,
what about mental health?
And I'm like,
I'm not talking about it in that avenue.
I'm just saying that guy that cut me
off,
you should kill himself.
Dictating should kill himself.
Oh,
set it.
There you go.
That's it.
That's the only clip they're going to
use from this entire podcast.
Dick Cheney should kill himself.
There's a few people that just like,
man,
come on.
What have you done?
That's ridiculous.
Some monsters out there for sure.
Just jump off bridges.
Wait,
what?
Oh,
that should jump off.
Then you think there's too many people
I'm sure.
And child molesters.
Jump off the bridge.
There's a lot of priests out there that
could definitely run into traffic,
but don't.
Don't do that because you fuck up
somebody's car.
Oh my God.
Jump off the bridge.
Right?
Not the worst thing to say,
look,
just this.
This game didn't go so well.
Just pull the plug on the console and
replug this pitch in and see what
happens is.
Then you drive it.
Flip the board.
Just it's over.
The game's over.
Knock the chess pieces down.
Just walk away.
There's definitely too many taboo words
today,
that's for sure.
I've been talking about this in my act
quite a bit lately because it's just,
where's this supposed to convey tent?
They're not.
They're not supposed to be magic taboo
words and half of it is not even about
trying to get people to be more
considerate or more kind.
It's about calling people out on doing
something wrong and stopping them.
Do you think the intent matters more
than the word hundred percent?
Because I feel like we saw that a lot
with um,
there's a,
there's two big youtubers that were in
the,
it was a or one was in the news,
there was a cutie pie.
Talk about that because I saw his
response video and I kinda got sickened.
Oh really?
By what's happening to him.
Oh,
by what's happening.
I thought you were saying you know his
words.
Well,
he was,
he was crazy.
It was crazy.
The whole thing's insane.
They're making it out like he's a Nazi
and he's not at all.
No.
He had made some,
some videos where he had told people to
not be Nazis and not until like to too.
Don't you know,
what was his exact words?
I don't,
I don't want them to this ripping.
It originally started with this whole
fiverr video that he did.
Um,
and then fiverr.
Yeah.
So it's like a website where you can get
people to do thing for things originally
for $5 now for more money.
And so he went through the site.
It all started from this one video that
got him attention.
He went to fiverr and try to get people
to do ridiculous,
outrageous things.
Okay.
Good guy dressed as Jesus to say
something weird.
He got these,
uh,
the main thing that blew up were these
two guys,
they're like,
they're in like a jungle setting of some
sort.
They dance,
they laugh,
they'll hold up a sign,
they'll say something.
And so he was like,
it's going to be hilarious because
they're not going to do it right.
They're going to be like,
thank you.
But no.
But they actually made a video where the
guys were laughing and dancing,
held up a sign that said a death to all
Jews and then said to subscribe to a
youtube channel.
Right.
The whole of,
uh,
of,
of someone else asked them to say death
to all Jews.
So he,
he wrote in as like a cause in the same
video.
He gets all these people that are like,
I'm not going to do the stupid
ridiculous thing that you said.
But then they actually did it.
The big reason I feel like they did it
as they didn't understand what the words
they were writing in the words that
we're saying,
oh,
they're from another country.
What country
were they from?
I don't know.
I'd have to,
I'd have to double check.
Okay.
So they just essentially wrote down the
symbols.
They didn't really know how to even say
the word.
And so there it is.
So there it is.
Oh yeah.
And they're laughing.
And so I think this might be from his
explanation video,
but in the first one he's like,
why the fuck did they do it?
How do I,
can I even include this?
And so then that sent,
that,
got that,
got a little traction and then people
started going through his other videos
and they're like,
he's,
he's dressed up,
he's watching Hitler in this one taken
completely out of context of him saying
that the Youtube Heroes Program,
which was a program where people can
highlight videos,
are not highlight them but mark them
down for deletion because they're
offensive.
Right?
And so people were like,
oh,
that censorship that's you're talking
about like obviously hyperbole.
It's like those are Nazis.
So he made that joke in that relation.
And then there was one,
if I want to say if it was on the verge
or wired,
but then they go even further and
they're like,
he was Leslie Jones.
Picture on Harambie taken completely out
of context because he was using,
there was this Microsoft Ai Bot,
this chat Bot,
and you'd say,
uh,
let me see Harambie as Jesus.
And uh,
either the AI was messed up or people
had manipulated it where it was putting
Leslie Jones his face on it.
And he was horrified by it.
And that was a whole joke,
but they were saying that he,
he was doing it.
So this is clear,
like he,
you saw him use the software and saw the
error.
You try and use the bot today.
A picture won't come up because now they
are aware that that's what was
happening.
Right.
And so they took all these things and it
was this like this crusade of,
look guys,
we're looking at this bad guy.
He's the biggest guy on youtube,
he's the bad guy.
We're going to take them down.
So much taken out of context.
Some things are not defensible where I
can't,
I can't say it in the sense of like you
say that words don't have power based on
intent.
And I think there's a,
there's a lot of truth in that.
Not saying words don't have power based
on intent.
I'm saying that words should just convey
intent.
Right?
And there are times where a word,
there's times where like you see a
friend,
Nico,
what's up bitch,
and you know,
you in there and you're both laughing
and being silly.
And then there's times where you call
someone a bitch because you think
they're being mean.
Yeah,
I mean those two words exactly the same.
But one conveys a completely different
intent.
Right.
But out of this it was,
it was very obvious that they were
trying to do this takedown thing and it
blew up entirely in their face I think
because I don't think most people are
aware.
I mean there was a Wall Street Journal
article.
All right.
Which was where it got really weird
because three people worked on this and
they combed through hundreds of hours
and they found like instances of him
holding his arm out like this.
And they used that picture.
Like there's A.
I mean that's,
that's weird.
Very weird.
And then,
and then once all that came out that
they were like,
well,
here's the thing about the context.
He's just like Donald Trump.
And it was,
it was an immediate jump to.
He's using the same tactic tactics as
Donald Trump,
but it was just insane.
Now
he's very reasonable.
He did a video response video about it
and the way he handled it was very
reasonable.
And he explained what he was doing and
what's going on and you know,
he's doing hundreds of hours of him
playing video games and talking and
being silly and if you comb through
those and take these things again out of
context and try to make it look like
he's a Nazi,
that's a hit piece.
One hundred percent.
And it's deceptive.
It's not indicative of his overall.
It's hard to call it a body of work,
but let's call it a body of work,
right?
His overall body of performance that's
online,
whatever you want to call it,
right?
His talking,
it's not who he is.
So for them to call him a Nazi and say
that pooty pie has seven videos where
he's done something about Nazis,
like people when they're doing these
long form spit ball,
improvisation,
videos like that,
and you're interacting with people,
you're going to say all kinds of shit
that in the moment is legitimate.
But if you chop it up and edit it and
splice them all together and then make a
five minute montage of him saying Nazi,
like he's obsessed with Nazis
and what,
what kind of sucked from it was a lot of
people think that,
oh,
they're there articles about the
downfall of Pewdiepie.
I think he's gone up half a million if
not more than a million subscribers
since all of this happened.
Right.
So he's gotten all this new support.
He's a temporary phase for a,
for free speech,
free speech and persecution for
mainstream media.
Didn't even lose some,
some get matter for him though.
He.
So,
I mean,
it sucks more for the people that we're
working on that project.
What was the project?
So it was scare Pewdie pie season two.
It was a youtube red series.
Um,
so they were,
I think there were about to go into
production.
Um,
and,
and so then that got canceled.
So Youtube didn't want to fund that.
And I said it,
he said it.
He understands why they would have to
separate because then it becomes a story
of youtube and or Youtube and Disney
support an anti Semite.
Right,
but that's.
He's not an anti Semite,
so why would they back away?
I think because they were scared that
the Wall Street Journal was like,
did you see all of this?
We're going to write this article,
Wall Street Journal at that slip
through.
That seems to me very response.
Many of them are standing by it though.
Many people,
yes.
One hundred percent and many are touting
it as this victory because he lost a
google preferred ads on Youtube,
which I will say I don't know how he was
still seen as family friendly because
I'm not family friendly on my show his
past two years at the very least not
family friendly and then dropped by
maker.
He doesn't,
he doesn't need his.
Uh,
his MTN has his company around him and
the youtube red series is nothing.
He's still gonna make millions of
dollars.
He's grown.
It's a good thing.
I feel like now if you,
if you have mainstream media,
try and take a swing at you.
It's some of the best promotion in the
world.
Why did they take a swing at him and why
is anyone saying that they took down a
bad guy?
I think
that it's a big thing of them trying to
label and it's,
once again,
it's a problem with a lot of media is
there.
They're overextending,
right?
They all of a sudden start talking about
this narrative about outright and the
rise of white again in this country.
And then they look at this big guy and
they're like,
we can use him as an example.
We can be the heroes that expose this,
that do the take down piece.
Um,
and they're not and they're not.
And they're like so driven for that,
that they then just,
they go,
oh,
well maybe that doesn't add up there.
It's an argument,
but we have the power.
We have the size of the audience were
good and it just blew up in their face.
So they were thinking they could get
away with it even though it wasn't
kosher.
I believe so too.
What is their response so far?
Do,
do you know?
Have you read anything about it?
Right as far as like fans or Wall Street
Journal posts,
posts,
digging their heels in,
and then a lot of people started trying
to find as always turned on like the
authors in the past one was like a joke
from 2015 because and,
and while part of me would go,
well that's petty.
If the argument is that context doesn't
matter,
then fine then then look at these guys,
what they said a year ago,
look at what they are saying now look,
the writers who have the article like I
think Ben Fritz was one of the art.
The writer is where you made A.
I can't,
I didn't,
I never knew that Jews were so good at
frying joke from way back.
And then he made another joke about,
it was like a back and forth with
someone where he said,
these racial jokes are so stupid.
And then someone said,
Eh,
you know,
they hit everyone.
And he said,
well,
at least the black jokes are funny.
Those ones,
those ones are funny.
Um,
and so people were like,
well,
if,
if context doesn't matter,
are you a scumbag?
And then people just dismissed it as are
a lot of mainstream people dismissed it
as like,
oh,
that's not the same thing.
How could anyone say context doesn't
matter.
That's insane.
That is an insane thing to say.
Is that literally what they said,
that context does not matter.
What was it?
It was one of the.
One of the people I'm going to get the
problem is so many people have written
about it.
There was one article that was promoted
and it said all these are articles or
all these people defending Felix with,
but context.
That's a bullshit argument and that's
insane if you think that that's.
So everything exists in a,
in a,
in a highly edited bubble,
dope,
ruined everyone's career.
If you're talking about a mathematician
discussing algorithms,
yes,
context doesn't really mean that much
because he's talking about numbers,
but we're not talking about numbers,
talking about words.
We're talking about the way people
express themselves and we're talking
about someone who is generally
considered to be humorous.
I mean pooty Pie,
a lot of his stuff is playful and
humorous,
so if your humerus and you're playing
around and you say something that might
be,
I don't even want to use the
appropriate,
it might be the thing for him to say in
that moment to try to be entertaining.
Right.
That does not mean he's a Nazi and two
to label him like that is incredibly
irresponsible and it's.
It's really bad.
I mean,
I'm not a lawyer,
but I would sue the fuck out of him if I
was him.
I would sue the fuck out of them for
sure.
Yeah.
Because what they're doing is
misrepresenting who he is as a human
being and even if it's beneficial in the
long run,
it's super dangerous to set that
precedent.
Well,
especially in this climate where you
say,
this is what he supports and it 100
percent isn't.
How do you know someone doesn't just see
those articles,
doesn't see as defense and tries to kill
the guy,
but why
Wall Street Journal do something like
this?
Now,
this is where the conspiratorially
minded start thinking,
this pooty pie kid is this youtube
sensation,
much like this Philip Defranco guy.
Oh,
I mean I have 5 million subscribers.
This guy has like $53,
million,
whatever.
That's still a lot.
It's a lot.
But do you feel,
and you're,
you know,
you have a legitimate viewpoint on this.
Do you feel like there is some sort of
resentment or anger or.
I'm so people that are working against
the folks that are,
have become these new media stars
because I mean,
you essentially mean,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but you kind of run your own thing,
right?
For the most part,
I am part of a company right now.
Yeah.
That was a financial decision that you
made along the way once you became
successful doing it in a year.
I'll be back on my own and uh,
and we're going to get threats.
This is where I start the negotiations.
No,
and in a year because if I,
because I want to start my own larger
news organization of people that are
from the left and from the Ryan can
debate like one of my favorite play,
a character.
I want to wear a fake nose and a
mustache.
Just talk shit and make things up and
lie.
I want to lie.
I want to be like a line news guy.
At first I thought muddied the water
for.
At first I thought you were talking
about Gavin,
but then you said the life that I was
like,
man,
he's a character man.
I funny motherfucker because I
originally knew him as a comedian and
then I found all the new stuff with or
maybe it's not that new,
but uh,
all his political stuff.
I like listening to the [inaudible]
not very new at all.
He was great the other day.
Was it yesterday?
How many days ago was that?
Yesterday was dominick Cruz two days
ago.
I do too many podcasts.
I know.
I was like,
how the fuck is he had on this?
Yeah.
Neil Tyson.
Dominic
cruise.
My name should not be on any list.
Neil degrasse Tyson.
I fucking love that.
Fuck is mind on.
It doesn't make any sense either.
He was awesome.
That was the Neil degrasse Tyson show.
It's basically like I threw a couple of
questions,
Adam and he just went on these epic mind
bending rants in your brain.
Oh,
I turned it inside out and then just
fucking hosed it down with bleach.
My brain will never be the same.
We can.
It was awesome.
Scotty.
So interesting.
He's one of the most fascinating people
I've ever talked to him because of his
passion for things like the way he
described space and astrophysics.
It's not just that he's so
knowledgeable.
It's the intense passionate in which it
delivers that information.
It's so infectious.
Well,
that's what separates people is the
passion relating everything to to art
that way and the lease.
It's relatable to everyone.
Everyone will.
It really is,
and there's an art form to the way he
does it.
I mean,
there's so many people.
I'm sure you probably experienced at
some point in your life,
a boring science teacher,
right?
We all have.
Where you just like,
oh my God,
it's so boring.
I would have thought that as an adult I
would be fascinated by sirens so that
will be constantly looking at science
blogs and reading all these scientific
papers and paying attention to every
single news release by NASA of new
exoplanets that they've discovered.
Passionate makes a difference.
I was in school,
I was way better at math,
but I was.
I was fascinated with storytelling
because I had a really passionate
English teacher really,
and I sucked at it initially,
but really got me into storytelling and,
and,
and the journey and the beauty of a
story and I feel like that we need more
people like that.
People that care rather than just
chasing the dollar.
Which,
hey,
no,
no disrespect for making money.
I,
I do feel like some people villainize
that,
but you have to have the passion.
Well for sure,
but it's the role of the school teacher
is such an underappreciated and
undervalued and also it's not just
undervalued under appreciated,
but when done incorrectly,
it's so fucking potentially damaging.
I mean,
you could really screw a kid's head up.
I don't know if anybody.
Did any teacher ever say mean shit to
you when you were a kid that stung you
and stayed with you for years and years
afterwards?
Um.
Oh shoot.
Well,
I had some,
some rough,
uh,
some,
some rough,
a Catholic school teachers,
but that was like,
that was early day,
so that was elementary.
That was,
that was stuff that maybe pushed me more
away from the religion.
I think later on it was probably my
Spanish teacher who was just so
disappointed.
Anytime I got anything wrong that it
just made me scared and made me a.
I didn't have any enthusiasm to all of a
sudden learn a new language.
And so now I'm this.
I'm one of these dumb fucks.
It only knows one language me to it.
Was it a man or a woman?
Woman.
Did she yell at you?
Yes.
Maybe she just wanted to fuck down,
Bro.
You know,
I was just trying to just get you
vulnerable.
The next thing you know,
come over my house.
I'm going to teach you Spanish.
I'm into children that are 170 pounds
and five foot tall.
You need to roll.
Oh,
I still can't do that.
I'm like,
wow,
whoa role now.
I got a dumb fat tongue.
Doesn't work.
Really.
You can't do it.
I'm like,
Rah,
I sound like a fucking car trying to
start up.
God Damn White people I know.
So just ruining everything now.
Wait,
so to jump back to,
to what you were saying about
mainstream,
do they have any real bad guy?
Yeah.
I get scared when everyone talks about
stuff in generalities right when I talk
about.
And I'm guilty of it too,
when I talked about like all mainstream
media.
It's not everyone you know.
Um,
but there are.
I stopped doing interviews with a
mainstream outlets several years ago
because they made everything about like
I would talk about all the really cool
ventures that we're going into,
how our space is changing things up and
it would always be turned into a one
comment that maybe was somewhat critical
of,
let's say like a studio all become about
that or if all become about the money.
And,
and I was like,
you just fucking manipulating what I'm
saying with this.
And so the point is become a.
When the Wall Street Journal knocks on
Felix's door after they didn't
apparently approach him for the original
story,
and they're like,
hey,
we want to give you a platform to tell
your story.
It's like,
fuck you.
Is that what they're doing now?
Yeah.
The after the story broke and there were
all these people that came to his
defense,
they came to him.
Now I'm not gonna.
I think that's what a journalist should
do.
Talk to the fucking.
May Not be different journalists.
Well,
so I think from what Felix wrote,
it was the Wall Street Journal.
They left their cards and that's how we
knew it was 100 percent of them.
But why does someone.
I mean what I mean is it different
journalists from the Wall Street Journal
not the same age to hit.
I don't know if it was the same ones.
He didn't seek out,
hey,
we're super sorry.
We called you a Nazi in front of
millions of people.
And we were totally lying.
Yeah.
But the argument all of a sudden is a
why,
why should he do an interview with the
Wall Street Journal?
Maybe because they have a different
audience,
but he has his own larger platform where
he controls the narrative.
He's not going to be selectively,
but he's not speaking to the people that
the Wall Street Journal risperidone him
in front of it,
but I would assume that they are also
covering their ass by going to him and
reaching out and giving him a platform.
They can say,
well,
we gave him a chance to respond and the
facts remain.
He did say those things and they are
valid.
I think if he was confident enough,
you should probably do what I've seen
Milo Yiannopoulos during the past where
he had someone film at the same time.
So
did ms dot represent him in some manner?
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter because they've
already done it.
They've already misrepresented him in
the article.
If they.
If he has someone film his response to
that.
I don't know.
I mean,
I mean just if he did something with
them,
right.
If I did film something,
I understood what the entire thing just
so you can show,
but I'm saying it doesn't matter because
they've already done the damage,
that damaging thing,
like how many people who read the first
thing or even going to read the second
thing,
right?
It might even be 30 percent.
That's 70 percent people and how many
people just read the Wall Street Journal
and maybe a local paper and our online
and aren't hearing all these responses.
And they go,
oh,
you know,
they catch their son.
Oh,
I'm watching pooty pie.
you watched that Nazi,
that a Nazi?
No,
he's not dead.
You hate everything I liked
and now that kid's doing meth,
but the rest of his life.
No,
I,
uh,
I think that it is sad,
right?
That's,
that's a huge problem with,
with a lot of the fake news or just news
that's false is the crazy salacious
shit.
If you then look at the correction,
half the time that gets like 20 times
the shares,
you know why?
Because it's fucking insane.
It's like,
did you see this?
Did you see this thing?
And it's something that I've been
critical of people I like in the
industry,
a critical level out of the mainstream
guys.
I don't like it.
And it sucks because there's not,
there's not a clear answer.
Do you delete the false thing?
And then it looks like you're hiding
that information.
Um,
do you do,
you should definitely delete the false
thing.
But.
So that's my argument.
But then there's,
there's an argument that you leave it up
because you show that you were wrong.
If it's on twitter,
you quote tweet it,
but that's still,
that's still doesn't fix it because
as much as we talk about bubbles and
separation,
that tweet,
that promotion of a thing is separate
from everything else in the world.
Tweets are problematic anyway because
it's 140 characters and it's very
difficult to adequately explained some
subjects in hundred 40 characters.
But if you put out some information
that's not true,
like this pooty pie thing,
right?
You,
you absolutely should print a retraction
and you absolutely,
if you have it still up on your website,
the first thing you should say is this
is all taken out of context and it's
incorrect and it's not.
It does not represent who this guy is
and you should absolutely not have those
writers do that again.
Right?
I mean,
whether you fire them or whether you
assignment,
who knows what they were asked to do.
This is another part of the problem.
Was this an independent thing that they
decided to pursue on their own?
Did someone ask them to do it?
Was there someone who decided that this
guy was a Nazi because maybe they tuned
in at the very moment he was doing
something and they're like,
make.
Some people obviously are very,
very sensitive to that kind of stuff,
so I think that's why it's important,
especially on an editorial team of some
sort to have people with with mixed
opinions because it's very easy to all
of a sudden get railroaded behind an
idea of just like,
yeah,
look at these.
Look at these seven specific things.
We're not gonna say that it's out of
context,
but look at this information.
We got this guy we got,
we got this guy dead to rights,
but it's.
It's all flimsy.
Well,
again,
context,
right?
As soon as you have.
That is part of the problem with doing
something like you do and it's certainly
part of the problem with a podcast is if
you're talking for three hours and you
take these little snippets of those
three hours out of context,
it paints a completely distorted
perception of who the person is,
but that's also a problem with language
in general.
It really is a problem with and it's
certainly a problem with words and
that's one of the problems with these
magic words like that.
You're not supposed to say anymore.
Whatever those words are there,
you,
you give the weight gives so much weight
to these words that just taken a loan on
their own.
They can get you in trouble.
Just saying,
uttering the phrase as if it was a
magic.
Abracadabra.
I think it get you in trouble.
I think it's important that we stopped
trying to got it rhymes and it's not on
purpose.
We have to stop just blindly hating and
we try and educate.
Right.
I think that don't blindly hate educate
an afterschool special star.
Oh God.
That sounds like straight up.
Something from the navy's skateboard.
You pull up.
Don't hate hate.
Educate.
Yeah,
but I mean if you want to talk about
allies,
you want to talk about people meeting
you.
Right.
There was.
If you turn it into the Trans issue,
right.
For the longest time I didn't want it
ever touch the issue because if I use
the wrong pronoun,
I was the fucking devil.
I was the devil and I was like,
just educate me at that time.
And this is years ago when at that time
I had never met anyone that was trends.
I was just a completely new concept to
me and,
and all of a sudden it was just like I
said,
he.
When I,
when I should have said she and it was
like I was the worst person in the world
and people want it to ruin me and ends,
but it's again,
what we're talking about before,
it's not really what they're doing.
What they're doing is trying to find a
way to control you and call you a bad
person and be angry at you.
They could see that it was a mistake or
if it wasn't a mistake,
you just look.
If someone was a heat for 30 fucking
years and they became a sheet for a year
and you still call him a he,
I don't think you're a monster.
Okay.
I just don't.
We knew Bruce Jenner for his entire leg
even saying Bruce Jenner.
Now you're not supposed to say it
anymore.
When you go and look at the records for
the fucking Olympics,
it says Caitlyn Jenner now.
Yeah.
Well,
is that true?
Is that real?
I'm pretty sure that's true.
He's like,
wait,
one second.
I'm go then.
I'm pretty sure it's true.
Um,
but so,
so,
right.
So,
so I think that's what pushed so many
people away.
And then the way that I try,
because I try and make,
I try to make it so no one's the villain
in my head so that I can see where
they're coming from.
I go,
well,
maybe that person,
maybe they're not.
Because there are definitely
professional victims and cry bullies out
there.
Maybe there's someone that in their day
to day life,
someone says,
you fucking tranny.
Maybe they say all this hateful stuff.
No,
I know.
But then they take it out on the wrong
person.
Right.
I try and see if is this person being
attacked so much that then they become
this,
this accidental monster,
which is what has pushed me more towards
the center.
I went before I came to California.
I was an ultra liberal.
I,
I hope the most liberal ideas of like,
yeah,
if I.
If I'm a doctor and I'm making
$3,000,000
a year,
I should give 70 percent.
Like fucking crazy.
Yeah.
You were thinking that because you
weren't a doctor because I had no
fucking money.
Fucking money.
Poor people always think like that.
You want to.
You want to slowly come to the center
and fucking start a business.
Um,
but,
but so and then being around people
everyday,
that's 100 percent because you see the
problems with many of the arguments.
Um,
it was,
I think also part of the reason I was
ultra liberal is there's definitely as
you're going up a counterculture thing,
and I grew up in the south so it was
just like everyone's wrong.
And I'm in North Carolina for a while,
Florida for a bit.
What part of North Carolina?
Asheville.
Oh,
that's like the hip hop part that's is
left is a gas.
Yeah.
But then you go,
you go,
you go around,
you start going out and like,
oh yeah,
just walk straight and you're eventually
going to run into a burning cross.
It's like,
it's like people in hacky sack and then
hate the writer of the quarter.
It's an awesome city.
That's great.
I guess you'd call it town.
It's really too small for a city,
but I played Asheville a few years back
to get back there.
That's amazing.
There you can go to the fuck was at the
biltmore house.
They go really small chairs.
What does that?
It's just like this giant,
giant comp.
I don't know the history of it,
but when I went there I was just like,
oh.
So people used to be like really short.
That's really interesting.
They really tiny chairs because that's
how people were back then.
They were just smaller,
shorter people didn't have any food.
Man Nourished.
If you go back there and give those
fuckers some God damn American brief.
I forget
who I was
listening.
I was blown away.
I also had the same belief that people
just died when they were 30.
Yeah,
it was Chris Ryan,
wasn't it?
I was looking.
Infant mortality fucks up the numbers
and that's the thing.
It's got to make sure people know that
no one's infallible.
You know?
Everyone can be wrong.
Like the.
It's one of those numbers that gets
incorrectly used.
Like the gender wage gap.
It's sort of another similar number that
gets incorrectly used.
People say like women make eighty cents
to every dollar a man makes.
Not really.
They do overall,
but it's not the same jobs.
It's not like the woman is a doctor and
Amanda doctor man makes a dollar.
The woman who makes eighty cents.
Now it's like the woman is a nurse and
the man is a fucking coal miner.
It's one of those things.
Yeah.
See,
that's one thing I'd have to dive deep
and educate myself on because I'm just
like,
yes,
that sounds legit,
but I have to check myself.
That's a weird one too.
What is this?
US Olympic Committee will update Bruce
Jenner's hall of fame plaque to say,
Caitlin,
I saw a headline this morning once I saw
a headline this morning that said like,
Caitlyn.
Caitlyn said something that like this
presidencies ridiculous.
And I was like,
why do we care?
We care more on.
She's a fucking moron.
Why do we care what celebrities?
But how about this?
Caitlyn Jenner doesn't believe in
fucking gay marriage issue.
Yes.
Gay Marriage.
I'm more of a traditional worst.
That's what she said.
Or more of a traditional last.
Uh,
you definitely not.
Okay.
I don't know what,
what traditions you're talking about,
but anytime any of these places get any
of these celebrities,
celebrities that have an opinion,
I'm like,
no,
I think the election proof,
no one fucking cares.
No one cares what these bucket people
said.
Especially Caitlyn Jenner,
like at the end of the day,
you don't get a free pass just because
you change your gender.
You're still judged based on the quality
of your thoughts and how you express
yourself and if you are a fucking grown
adult and you are against gay marriage,
but you're also transgender.
Your crazy and I know she's buck buckled
down for because of some of the pressure
that people put on it like Ellen and she
kind of like soft into her stance on it,
but the bottom line is you're in your
fucking sixties and you don't think that
men should be able to get married.
If they're in love with each other.
You're out of your mind or women or
anybody just fuck off.
It's your stupid.
See,
I feel like
I feel like more and more people when I
started hearing about like this,
this new kind of Republican I thought it
was,
and I've seen a lot of people will know.
So a lot of people have then talked
about,
well it's,
there's this weird thing where it's like
all of a sudden you say new kind of
Republican.
And they go,
oh,
so you're talking about white
supremacist under a whole different
banner.
I'm talking about when I was talking
about where people that Republicans,
I don't give a fuck about gay people
getting married and they're like,
I'm about,
I'm Republican because,
you know,
small government,
right?
And,
and,
and jobs.
But not like if gay people get married,
that's fine.
If it's,
if it's a moral issue like that,
I find myself more liberal and I was,
I all of a sudden became kind of excited
about all these,
these new people that didn't give a
fuck.
And that was interesting to me.
But then when you really see a lot of
other stuff that I don't know how to
feel about a lot of other stuff that you
don't know how I feel about.
What do you mean after?
I think I had to say it.
Don't beat around the bush.
No,
no.
I'm trying to think how to say it
because there's these all these fucking
different avenues.
There's some people that um,
they,
they'll maybe consider themselves all
right because they just love fucking
trolling people.
Like how do I,
how do I trigger someone with some crazy
outrageous thing?
Right.
And it's like I get it.
But then there are people then that you
can take it a whole different avenue
where it's known that,
that,
that thing,
it is now white supremacy that pepe the
frog.
It is.
And to the point where it fucking.
Hillary Clinton puts a thing on our
website where she's like,
this is a white supremacist symbol.
That's insane.
But what is the frog?
Remember?
Pepe the frog get there.
Like it is 100 percent of whites
premise.
She put that on her website.
Yes.
This was because Donald trump people
were using that frog to troll online,
overextend.
You look like an idiot.
Okay,
but here's.
Here's part of the problem when you're
talking about people who troll online,
go back to when you were a young liberal
and you thought that if I was a doctor
and I was making $3,000,000
a year,
of course I should be given 70 percent
in taxes.
You don't have that,
so you're looking at the people who do
and it's part of you is like,
give it away,
man.
You shouldn't.
You don't deserve it.
Give it away.
That same mentality exists with trolls.
They don't have anything going on.
They're fucking losers for the most
part.
So what do they want to do?
They want to burn it all down.
They want the whole thing burned down.
Go trump,
go try.
I want the reason why they want to say
go tropos because they want this clearly
maniacal person to just throw a fucking
monkey wrench into the gears and watched
the whole system explode.
That's half of what they're doing.
They don't have a vested interest in it.
They're not.
They're not successful.
They're not happy,
they're not doing well.
I think their role is,
if you're talking about all trump
supporters,
I think part of that is true.
I'm not talking about all.
Okay,
okay.
Because I was talking about all trump
supporters.
I'm talking about trolls.
Those people with the green frog fucking
with the crazy hair on their twitter
profile.
I mean there's a lot of them that if you
go over their twitter feed,
their online 13 hours a day,
shitting on people.
I mean that's some people do.
I've gone.
I looked at this,
a few people that I follow and I don't
follow them either.
I just go to their pay to have them
bookmarked and I'll go to their page
like,
look at this crazy asshole.
What's he been up to today and what
they've been up to.
Just trolling liberals.
Just going crazy and shitting on that.
Jake Tapper Guy,
boy fucking guy's twitter feed is a
mess.
Why?
Because he,
he fucking summon the ire of the trolls.
There's a lot of people out there that
are disenfranchised and very upset and
unhappy and,
and just can't wait to burn it down.
They just want to burn it all down.
They don't have any fucking stake in the
game.
They want it to burn,
you know,
but then where,
where do we go from that?
I need
love.
Okay,
so it's too late.
It's too late.
They get shitty parents.
They live in a shitty neighborhood.
Their job sucks.
They probably have poor genetics.
They're fucked.
They got to shit handle life and they're
looking at Kate Upton.
He's handsome man.
He is.
He's a closet troll.
You don't even know the opposite of a
troll.
They're looking at Kate Upton and her
beautiful tits and they're like,
fuck her.
Fuck everybody burned down.
Why can't I have this?
Oh conor Mcgregor's got a limousine.
Light them on fire.
That's what they're doing.
They're mad.
They're not happy,
they're not successful,
and they get to talk.
That's a big part of what you have in a
society where people are being
incredibly mean at every opportunity.
When people have the opportunity to
troll people are like,
did you see like some of the shit that
people wrote to patent Oswald after his
wife died?
No,
I didn't see anything crazy vicious mean
evil shit.
And why do they do that?
Because they want to burn it down.
The one thing I think it's part of it,
part part is going to be that they want
to burn it down,
but I think it's just also there are a
lot of people that don't have the
concept of shit that we do online having
potentially horrible ramifications in
the real world.
I think that slowly we're getting closer
to that where it's all the fucking same
thing and if you do some crazy,
outlandish shit,
you should know that a ton of people
might see it.
It's why it's one of my favorite things
to screenshot and and,
and talk back to a few people that say
stupid shit to me online just because
it's like you think that you're saying
it in this tiny room,
but the Internet's fucking everybody in
a room.
Everyone like what you say has
ramifications.
Well,
not only that,
you shouldn't want to say it,
so you have to get to the root of the
problem.
Like,
what?
Why would someone want to be so evil?
Why would someone want to hurt someone's
feelings so badly that you're mocking
his.
I think there are a lot of people that
fit just died.
So that's,
that's a fucking horrible emotional
example.
But when and why?
Right.
So what I would say separately from
that,
if you're talking about trolling
liberals or something like that,
um,
I think that there are people that want
to burn the whole thing down.
And then I think there are some people
that literally they have the mindset
that it's just for laughs,
right?
Well,
it's,
that's not him.
Yeah.
And so,
and so it's one of those things where I
don't know,
I don't think was people are inherently
evil.
I think that especially if you're
talking about like a Patton Oswald thing
that's incredibly wrong and horrible,
but it's like,
Mike,
my question becomes like,
how do I,
how do I talk to that person?
Right?
How do I not a,
how do you talk to who?
Patton Oswald with trolls,
the trolls when you got to go back in
time to when the mother was raising them
and take them away from the Mama and
bring them to a happy person and give
them love and lots of hugs.
I think people,
as long as,
as long as you don't automatically call
someone the villain,
I think that you can get some people,
not all of them because some people,
like you said,
they want to call them the villain when
they're a troll,
when they're evil.
So is that what you mean?
Yes.
When they're maybe saying something they
would see as evil and things when I'm
not talking about the patent Oswald
situation,
because if you go after someone grieving
over their wife,
you're a fucking horrible monster and
hopefully you.
You do understand that that has a real
world ramifications or not.
If you're just an,
you might be able to get
away with it.
He just a little egg,
you know,
fuck face 69 on twitter and you can get
away with it.
They'll ban your account,
whatever.
Ha Ha.
Yeah,
I got them.
I mean,
that's what you're doing and trying to
get a reaction.
It's like you're playing a game.
You're right,
you're playing operation and when that
tweezer hits the sides and like,
hi,
I saw it.
It happened.
It was a thing.
Yeah,
it was a thing,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just,
I'm not gonna do it myself.
Of course,
you know,
but I want to,
I want to try and talk.
I want to talk to people,
man.
You do.
Why don't you like that?
You have a show,
reach out show like A.
it'll be hell for two weeks and then
it'll just be.
I'll get,
I'll end up on one of those fucking
Howard stern things where they just have
those people that get trolled the entire
time.
It's like we have another caller.
God Damn.
It could be windy city heat.
You could have a whole movie about it.
Yeah.
They don't need to know about it.
Yeah,
I,
I just,
it's,
it's a,
a new thing.
It's a new thing for human beings.
This unbridled communication ability.
Yeah,
and there's going to.
Here's the thing,
there's going to be the whole like,
let's destroy each other war.
I'm just going to try and be the asshole
that's in the middle with with leanings
here and there that tries to go like,
hey,
maybe we fucking calm down.
That's not the best thing for my career
because I would have a far larger
audience if I,
if I pandered to just one side because I
alienated people daily by having left
views and then right views.
Wait,
that's so crazy.
You will,
you really think that your audience
would be bigger if you just picked a
side.
Yes.
Are you kidding me?
Like,
who?
I think that crowd is very favor.
Crowder is fantastic.
He's very,
he's one of the fair guys.
Um,
but I think he does a great job.
You have a bigger audience in,
you know,
oh,
bigger than me.
You're crazy.
Your audience is way bigger than his.
You have five fucking million youtube.
I mean,
daily active as like a million.
So.
Right.
That's a lot.
Right?
But I'm talking Tomi Lahren is a
fantastic example.
Okay.
Tomi Lahren hits tens of billions on
facebook.
Example,
hot girl and the conservative Jews out
there,
grease in their guns,
the decanter lefthand that are super
excited about that.
They love
a hot conservative Va.
She's mean she don't like mexicans,
but she is very one side,
right?
Yes.
It can be under the veil of.
I hate Snowflakes,
but there's,
there's hypocrisy in that a little bit
in the sense of every time she's
screaming,
she does seem like a snowflake on some
of the topics,
but putting things,
don't you think that's for effect though
for dramatic effect because half of it
is performance.
All right,
but that's the thing,
right?
But it's aimed at one group of people
and you've seen the massive rise where
it started as this kind of small thing.
It blew up.
Now you see her on fox news,
but she doesn't even need that because
she has a giant platforM.
It's definitely a good move for her to
be on fox news.
Right?
It's a different audience,
but it is playing to one side.
I still don't think she's as big as you.
I think so.
Nothing.
So go to her.
Her,
um,
her twitter feed.
Find out what
our twitter feed is,
how many she has,
and then go.
How many twitter feed people you got?
800,000.
I'm not huge on a bet shit.
I'm actually as the last.
What about her?
Did she have to look at the engagement
though?
Because she mentioned you're one of
those guys.
You paying attention.
I don't pay attention to.
No,
that's no.
You don't care about the engagement.
if you're a sales guy and you're like,
he has 5 million.
What did she got here at 6:40.
Oh,
you've got a beat or engagements or
engagements?
A little low.
how weird.
Oh,
she's got her.
Hashtag final thoughts.
Fuck off tommy.
Oh fuck.
Off of your final thoughts.
Get outta here.
She,
like you were saying whether you
consider it,
whether you consider it performance art,
whether you consider it anything and it
plays one side and it has been a very
massive successful rise.
I think that,
but what I want to do for the longterm.
Okay.
He is not taking that into account.
Like you're saying that if you went one
way,
show me another guy who's gone one way
who looks like you have reasonable,
normal looking fella.
You're not a thing.
Some super buff,
a pro athlete or some,
uh,
androgynous weirdo that people can't
take their eyes away from your,
just a regular guy
king if you're looking at maybe like
monthly views on owned and operated
sites,
youtube,
all the other places.
Uh,
the young turks who I'm not really a
like,
I know them,
but I'm not a fan of the messaging a lot
of the time.
They're massive.
I think they get more,
been around a long time doing that stuff
though.
They get a lot of monthly views,
but they also get a lot of hate,
man.
There's a lot of people that hate watch
jank comments.
Woo.
They go after him.
He should have.
He should watch youtube for like a
binder.
We could only look at the video shit on.
We can't read the comments at all.
Hire someone that only reads the
comments,
don't read them at all.
Don't even engaged.
Stay away.
That I liked.
I liked the conversations on mine
though.
I mean you have people that are,
that are really passionate,
but then there are a lot of threads
where it's like people having
conversations that didn't work normally
agree with each other.
While I'm saying this,
the whole reason why I said in the first
place is more of a compliment than
anything.
I think it's a great thing that you're
very.
Like,
here's a perfect example.
The way you handled the milo
yiannopoulos thing.
I think you're very fair and I think.
I think it's great that you're neither
left nor right,
but rather reasonable.
You know,
you're reasonable and considered and I
think that's one of your strengths.
I don't think you would have a bigger
audience if you just went all right.
I think you'd be a big old phony and
less less.
You became felina and then then you,
you,
you got some tits and put on a nice
little dress and then you could wear
like a sleeveless shirts,
you know,
because right now if you wear sleeveless
shirts,
you're a douche bag because you're a
male,
right?
If You're a man and you show your arms,
you're a piece of shit,
so I got to start going to the gym
because I no one wants to see that.
Now
they would.
Maybe they'd be lIke lena dunham type
thing,
even bigger.
So if you're going to go and become a
woman,
you either become a hot woman or a
fucking sloppy one.
A really sloppy one who celebrates food
and this is who I am.
Love it.
Or leave it.
Fuck off.
I find that finally
the lena dunham's end up doing more
damage to their cars then then good.
Or she has 100 million twitter followers
and she's got food stuck in our teeth
and no one gives a shit.
Big old fuck.
Fucking sloppy arms like a,
like a 300 pound man's legs.
This is nothing wrong with it.
I,
uh,
I remember like a few days before the
election,
she put out this fucking animated video
where she was talking with her dad and
was the,
it was the death of the white male.
And I was like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Women empowerment by destruction of
another dope.
Amazing.
She's doing it all on a platform
invented by white males.
How bizarre.
True,
true gel.
It's called the internet.
Actually.
I know al gore and he invented his movie
so white.
Well,
the death of the white male,
but whether it be like,
well,
those people don't want to fuck me.
Death.
Oh god.
When it was the odell beckham jr thing,
did you see that?
This was a while ago.
She sat at the same table and she wrote
this whole post about how he looked at
her like she was a piece of garbage and
he was like,
what?
What are you talking about?
I was just trying to be humorous.
Did you say the humorous thing?
I dunno.
It's because I think she,
because she wrote this.
Then apology where she was like,
it was all in my head.
It's like,
ah,
got it.
Did you try to not mention her as much
as possible,
but it happens so often.
You know,
the weirdest thing was how she was
giving a free pass for sexually
assaulting her young
cisco.
The weird like shoving things up her
vagina when she was little.
Like,
what will.
So that's where,
that's where when you say like,
I'm reasonable with the milo thing,
well,
because you have to take into context
other other people,
right?
Is it,
is it a hit job,
but also what you said earlier where
people are human beings and like let's
talk it out.
So milo said some,
some things that even he said he
apologized for others,
he said was misconstrued but.
But it's.
And then there's the george decay thing
which is different but still the same
two k thing you have to explain to
people because most people have no idea
what you're talking about.
So sorry.
Yeah.
So this is a problem for me.
I have conversations in my head that
then I,
other words here are just so entrenched
with media.
So much shit coming into your head
everyday.
The assume everybody else is watching
the same video.
So they're,
they're actually living their lives.
so they went on,
they did a hit piece on george decay
essentially to sort of show that george
takei.
Well,
he was talking about his own personal
experiences when he was very young with
a camp counselor who did some sexually
inappropriate things to him,
but he was talking about them in a very
positive way that he enjoyed it and
people are saying george decay is
promoting sex amongst 13 year olds as
being okay.
No,
he's talking about his own personal
experience and being honest about it.
Well,
and then the way that ends up becoming a
comparison is the.
Because it ends up being this weird
argument of numbers of lines in the sand
where he said,
I said 13 because that's when I had my
first experience.
Then we talked about the the age of.
Oh god,
I'm trying to remember.
He talked about the age of 14,
which was a,
I think when you were.
So that was a conversation he had with
you with the situation.
Right.
And then people were pointing out that
it's his.
His mindset changed and my argument
there was what you're talking about.
To me,
even if he at the end,
at any point before,
before he acknowledged it,
it to me it sounded like he was a victim
and,
but then that creates the argument too
of if someone's a victim early in life,
what does that excuse later on?
Now I'm not making the argument that
milo then went on to do and became a
sandusky,
right?
He,
he was having a conversation and it's
words,
but at what point do we excuse things?
And that's just like,
that's a conversation I'd like to have
where it's,
it's not damning.
I don't want to go in on a victim,
but also at the same time I'm going,
it's fucking weird to me and I think
it's completely wrong if you have an
adult,
let's try and fuck a 13 year old.
I think that's completely wrong.
Like just when you feel like you always
have to put people in,
in your,
uh,
in,
in their shoes.
Where if I was a parent and I'm dropping
my kid off the fucking middle school and
I find out some 25 year old is fucking
my son that's going to.
I'm going to go to jail,
but that's gonna be a fucking dead
person.
A dead person.
One hundred percent that someone's
molesting my child.
No.
Done.
Yeah,
I mean,
I completely feel you and I understand
what you're saying.
I think with the milo situation is very
bizarre because I think there is
irreparable damage done to people when
they're molested as children and I think
milo has been really clear about the
fact that he was molested and he's tried
to paint it in a positive light,
but he tries to paint a lot of fucked up
things in a positive light and it could
easily be his rationalizing and trying
to figure out.
No one wants to be a victim in their own
life.
Made it a positive thing.
Control it was him.
Yeah.
So that's why I say like,
let's,
let's think of it in that way.
Rather than going,
he's against me.
Let's just destroy him.
Well,
I think the besides outlandish thing
that milo does that.
I mean,
he's a merchant of outrage.
That's his business and when people get
outraged back at him and if somehow
another sticks like this pedophile
stuff,
you can't be upset.
This is the game that you just started
to play.
If you get knocked the fuck out,
you know if your bike tyson and all of a
sudden you get knocked out,
are we supposed to feel bad for you?
You've been knocking people out your
whole career.
This,
he's a merchant of outrage.
If it's valid,
if the outrage is valid and I think it's
valid.
I think that what they're saying about
what he was saying is absolutely valid.
If he says that there can be incredibly
positive relationships between very
young men and our young boys rather an
older gay men and that this could keep
men from suicide,
hit the brakes,
stop.
No,
it's fucking illegal for a reason and
you could potentially be encouraging
someone whose fence sitting right now
thinking about fucking kids to hop right
over to the other side and start doing
it because it was positive for my low.
It does because it was beneficial.
It is the conversation
also to that extent.
There might be someone that is 13 that's
being abused that all of a sudden it
feels like that's normal.
Right.
So,
but let's,
let's talk about it.
I 100 percent,
don't agree with the words.
It is a tricky situation because you are
talking about someone that was a victim
of a heinous crime and then just talking
about talking about it and going from
there.
But it's also he said that he was gay at
the time.
He knew he was gay and he was.
The sexual predator in every situation
has its own variables.
Right.
And in his look,
he's clearly a damaged guy.
OkAy.
And I liked him.
He's clearly a damaged guy,
but the way he lashes out and the way he
gets attention,
I don't like the left's reaction to him.
I like that far less than.
I like what he's saying.
I feel like with a guy like milo,
he's not doing any real violent things.
He's not doing any real damage.
And what you should do is confront him
with words,
bait him,
pick apart his arguments about feminism,
about transgender people,
about gay rights,
because he's got some crazy writes
about,
he's got some crazy thoughts about gay
people and he's gay.
He thinks that it's a choice and he
thinks that it's a,
it's offensive.
And if he could have a pill to not be
gay,
you would take it in a heartbeat.
And like he said,
all kinds of crazy shit.
What do you have someone like milo or
anyone else?
The number one thing shouldn't be,
let me silence that person.
Right?
Because that's just going to one,
bolster them,
validate them,
let them talk.
Right?
So when,
when you see situations like,
like berkeley,
where I did see,
I had people that sent me videos and
there was like,
there was a protest in the beginning
that it was just people being outspoken
and there's a fucking crazy chaos.
People I know that you've talked about
before,
of like the people getting sprayed in
the face with fucking pepper spray
people beaten in the streets.
Obviously.
I hate those people.
What?
What I really,
really hate is the people that aren't
doing that,
they're like,
yeah,
that's what we should be doing that
aren't doing like,
are you fucking crazy?
You think this is a positive.
You think this bolsters your argument
that that we're going to go against what
we don't agree them that they're saying
with fucking violence.
You think that makes you the winter.
That's insane.
It straight up and saying,
well,
it's also the.
They put these blanket labels.
He's a nazi.
He promotes genocide.
He,
they say all these things and they say
these things so that they can attack.
Well,
there was a whole.
Yeah,
that whole.
He's a fascist nazi movement.
After Richard Spencer got punched in the
face,
which once again,
who's Richard Spencer or.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Am I getting the name wrong now?
The guy that will double check.
Go ahead.
You've.
You've made me doubt myself.
Now he's part of a two,
two,
two.
You might be right.
I mean I'm definitely.
I just don't know who it is.
Yeah,
you always.
You always see his face.
He just got booted out of c pack for my
understanding,
so he's.
He talks
about just look them up.
You're not going to.
I imagine you aren't going to be a fan,
but people were like,
he's a literal nazi.
We got to punch these people that people
like overjoyed,
so he really is a nazi people just happy
supremacist.
This guy,
I don't want to.
I don't want to label this guy on it.
I think that you would call himself a
white nationalist or anything like that
on the website.
Oh,
he's neo nazi nazi everywhere.
I don't know if he calls himself that.
I'll double check.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
I don't want to.
I don't want to slam a label on someone
and then do that thing.
Right.
So it's hard,
but.
So he got punched in the face.
Everyone fucking cheered for it,
but the problem is then then they move.
Then you move.
The goalposts have,
who's a fucking nazi.
All of a sudden cutie pies.
A fucking nazi ever.
Ever.
Everyone's a nazi and we can just be
violent.
Punch nazis.
Yeah.
The punch nazi thing.
And so the whole.
The whole thing is just debate these
people,
right?
So like just just let them be their own
undoing if they are actually that wrong.
Well,
I think there's a.
Does a giant problem with groups humans
when groups of humans get together.
I mean that phrase mob mentality exists
for a reason.
It's not,
you don't say mob mentality.
People go,
why?
Whatever.
Do you mean philly date?
What?
What is a mob mentality?
No,
people know it happens.
Giant groups of people face something
called diffusion of responsibility and
that means when chaotic events are going
on,
they don't take responsibility for their
own actions because they're a part of
this gigantic,
chaotic movement and I personally,
and this is just totally unfounded.
I'm definitely not a scientist.
I think he came from war and I think
people are used to large scale tribal
war and I think it's been going on for
so long and the atrocities that are
required for you to survive and war,
like battle axes and shit,
braveheart style.
I think once that breaks out,
you'd lock into this massive mind sync
with all the people around you and you
use.
Except this violent chaos and I think
that happens on campuses when people
burn it down,
that is the same mindset.
EveryoNe is involved in this,
this hurricane of chaos and you just get
swept up in this mob mentality and it's
a really dangerous thing.
You know,
like I'm sure you saw the girl that got
maced in the Face that had the matan
bitcoin great again hat and he hit her
over the head with a stick.
Like,
what in the fuck are you doing?
Yeah.
If you think that's okay,
I think you're in the wrong 100 percent.
It's just a girl.
Just a girl nonviolent non non non
motion.
She was,
she was stationary.
She's not threatening whatsoever.
I think if you listen to the audio
before all of it happens outside of that
clip,
she's,
she's literally saying,
I'm actually surprised things are pretty
calm here because sometimes things go
out of hand and then 20 seconds later
pepper spray to the face,
they just decided that her hat was a
trump hat and so they just blasted her.
It wasn't even a trump hat.
I mean,
it's just,
it had the right font so she had to get
punished and that's so I feel like
that's the big thing of understanding
whether it'd be a 60 year old maN that
did it to her too,
or she don't know that something insane,
don't know that.
Find out that because someone,
someone told me that,
that it was a 60 year old man that
a pepper sprayed her in the face.
So,
I mean obviously we're talking about
different kinds of severity,
but there are people on both sides and
it's,
it's important to acknowledge that,
that want to burn the whole fucking
thing down.
Whether it be a person or an argument
for your 60 year old man,
you're still a fucking loser and there's
a pretty girl in front of you and you're
like,
fuck you.
And I was young.
Uh,
yeah.
Nazis.
It's ridiculous,
man.
I,
I'm a very much of the belief that we
have rather than more and more people
are putting in talking about
generalities where it's the left versus
the right.
I feel like a lot of the conversation,
a lot of the stories end up being about
these,
these far left and far right.
People that are like fucking pack
manning their way to the middle and just
slowly absorbing more and more people
into,
into their opinion.
And what's scary is if they ever do get
to the center,
right.
If it does become all of us in a,
an us versus them on facebook,
it's a lot closer to that in real life.
so how,
so after the.
After the election,
I don't know about your personal like
family and friend group,
but how many people like cut off contact
with each other for awhile because on
mine,
holy fuck.
It was like war.
It was war ending of relationships that
had,
had been longer than a decade.
And sally,
your family,
family members,
some of most of it,
a lot of its extended,
extended family.
What happened?
Just just people just saying like,
well one there was,
there was a,
I come from a family that they're,
they're fine with like independence.
So there was rIght after the election,
there was that whole like all
independence did this.
Even in California,
if you voted for fucking anybody,
you voted for jill stein,
you took away from client.
Do you know how the electoral college
works?
You fucking idiot.
Oh,
California is going to go to someone
else.
But yeah,
just people going to each other because
they're like,
if you voted for trump,
you're a racist,
sexist,
a monster.
And if you voted for hillary,
you wanted people to not have healthcare
and she's a fucking crook and should be
in jail and just train the swamp.
Yeah,
I went to,
I went to like,
I love the people I work with,
but I went like emotions were high.
People at the,
at my office were like,
we have a team of like 40 outside of my
group of people were crying like it was
chaos.
I know dude who was in the cia and he
was telling me about his office where he
works at.
One of the women at the office was
openly weeping.
Oh wow.
And he's like a,
hey,
that's a.
Can't do that here.
This is a place for that.
This is a week free zone who can't weep
over democracy.
Not going your way.
I mean for a lot of.
For a lot of liberals I knew it was like
a national day of mourning.
Yeah.
And then for,
for everyone else that voted for him
though,
it was the day that will always
remember,
oh,
there's a lot of people that were super
happy,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
I feel like everyone was was either like
burning bridges or coming out to their
Friends in a way of like friends and
family as trump supporters because there
are a lot of people that were scared.
Yeah.
Well I think
that he represents a lot of very
dangerous things and he in a lot of
people's eyes,
this is the death of responsibility.
He can get away with more things and
then also these all the different
business ties and different
entanglements and all the different
things and and also just the way he
communicates that like people don't feel
like it's statesmen lee and it's not.
It's not representative of what they
would like to think of as someone who is
the president of the United States.
They want to think about someone who's
incredibly noble and well spoken and the
best representative that we can have,
you know,
like,
forget about obama's policies.
Okay.
Just forget just him as a human being,
standing in front of that podium,
talking as the president was a joy in
that.
He was very measured and very calm and I
think that he is also very articulate
and very well educated in that thing
that he represented when he was up there
at that thing.
The president don,
that figurehead that he represented,
he did such an amazing job of
representing that because he was
exceptioNal.
He's an exceptional man.
He's exceptionally smart.
He's exceptionally well read.
He's,
the way he communicates is smooth and
even the way he's responded to criticism
was very well measured,
you know.
So I,
I though he did fuck up when he was
joking aRound about trump back in the
day,
you know,
like he was like,
we was joking about trump's criticism of
him.
But uh,
you know what,
I'm one thing that you'll never be the
president.
Dope.
So I agree.
I agree with what you said about like,
I think he's going to be one of the most
well spoken presidents of my lifetime.
Yeah.
Well received.
But after the fact,
there's going to be a lot of people that
look at that and go,
yes.
But it was all phony.
It was all,
it was all an act from trump.
Trump may speak six syllables at a time
and break and then go on tangents.
Thanks.
Hey,
it's in the bubble bad thing.
It's in the bubble of that arm brace.
But,
uh,
I feel like there are people that go,
you know,
he's not the best speaker in the world,
but he's more real.
Right?
So there's gonna be that argument.
I 100 percent agree with you about obama
as far as like the,
the office and the nobility.
But they're going to be people that say
it's just,
it's just bullshit.
That's why we needed something
different.
Maybe.
But you know,
there's other,
there's other people that look at the
whole thing and they say this is a well
needed break from the system that,
you know,
there's things,
a big test.
It's a test of our system that have been
controlling the system.
People that were deeply entrenched in
the left and deeply entrenched in the
ride for so long that he's the first
businessmen that has been.
He's been a participant in our system.
He's been essentially paying these guys
off for years and years and now here he
is like,
like he talked pretty openly,
which I thought was hilarious about
hillary and bill coming to his wedding
and
that the reason why they did is because
he paid them,
you know?
I mean,
he paid them,
I think it was more than $100,000
for them to come to his wedding.
Oh wow.
yeah.
That's just how they do things.
Do you mean like,
do you think he literally paid them
where he gave them a donation and then
there were like donation.
I mean,
let's be real about what the clinton
foundation is.
Whether or not it did good work.
It's a goddamn pay to play operation and
one of the things they got besides the
donations,
which I'm sure did go to charitable
causes,
they got paid to speak and they didn't
just get paid to speak a little.
They got paid to speak hundreds of
thousands of dollars and they did it
over and over and over again.
Both bill and hillary and there's a
reason why,
just for the same reason why trump
release his taxes,
hillary won't release the transcripts of
those speeches that she gave to the
banks because they would be horrific.
If they weren't horrific,
she would release them.
It'd be really simple.
No,
I said some great things about income
equality and how we all need to,
you know,
support the impoverished communities.
Fuck you.
You dId because did you had released
that and everybody would go,
oh,
even though hillary is worth millions
dollars,
she's super fair.
She's reasonable.
No,
there was none of that.
The reason there's a reason,
it's a corrupt system,
man.
It's a system that they figured out how
to find loopholes and they've created
legislation over the years that have
allowed them to skirt through these
weird sort of fucking avenues of,
of legality,
and they get to this point where they're
making insane amounts of money as a
public servant.
I meaN,
bill clinton and hillary clinton have
earned hundreds of fucking of millions
of dollars and doing what?
Do you have a business?
Are you selling laptops?
What are you doing?
You,
you have a new car to you're selling.
Where are you making all thiS fucking
money?
Oh,
just talking how weird.
You're making hundreds of millions of
dollars talking when you used to be the
president who's paying you?
Oh,
this is weird.
THe people that are paying you are the
people that benefited from you being in
those.
Wait a minute,
did they pay you off?
Are you stiff?
Right.
But that's the argument and that's what
it is.
And that's the drain.
The swamp shit.
I mean,
that's where it came from.
So donald trump's not guilty of that.
So that sort of thing,
that thing that he's not guilty of
getting paid hundreds of millions of
dollars to talk and to give his
influence as a,
as a person who's serving,
whether it's the senate or someone who's
a president that's not while he's.
While he's getting that money.
So he's.
He's corrupt in a totally different way.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's a,
he's a special one because it's special
one.
I don't know.
I get it.
I get exhausted about it and I hate even
talking about it.
People were mad at right now.
Are they,
are they hitting you?
I'm sure they are just imagining rogan.
No.
IF you don't know anything about
politics,
which the right.
I should probably shut the fuck up by
learning more and then get more upset
and then talk more.
I used to joke about.
I mean I still do it from time to time
that I would want to be president,
but when you see these dudes become
president,
they look,
they look like they like one month in,
they look like they're in a race they
didn't train for.
Somebody should have a picture of trump
now.
I know he talked to at seapak this
morning and he was on the prompter is,
but I was just like,
I don't know if it's the white balance
on this video,
but.
Oh wait,
what's this?
My friend cameron hanes.
Keep hammering five k,
the only race I've ever run.
I ran a five k asked me many times.
I ran a train for it.
Seven zero.
I thought it would be zero,
but I thought we're going to fuck with.
I ran the rate.
I didn't trade at all,
so that's the same thing.
She caught me at the end of that race.
I was like,
whoa,
that's hard to do if you'd like to here
in shape.
So a lot longer than.
I thought it was more difficult to run
five k than it seems.
It seems like I've worked out all the
time.
This is for pussies,
so I'll just go run it now.
I think if you think that you could be
the prentice,
the president,
like I have amazing stamina.
I have a winning mentality,
a winning temperament,
you know,
like once you get in there,
man,
that guy looks bewildered.
THat press conference that he did the
other day where he's just going on and
on about everything.
Holy shit.
That was terrifying to me,
but I had friends that are conservatives
at texted me afterwards go,
he looks unstable.
This is making me nervous.
Like,
wow,
there you go.
Well,
because you're making America great
again.
You fucks.
Kellyanne conway hasn't been on tv for
awhile,
but what?
Like some of the last one,
she was just looked like she was
wrecked.
They got her in a bunker somewhere.
They're feeding her adderall and the
tone of what to say.
She's just like,
I don't know if I could do this.
I would.
I would probably collapse under it all
for sure.
I would call out.
I would.
I would decide everything on fucking
internet polls.
Like you fucking run this thing too.
I first of all,
I'd be drunk on tv all the time.
I'd be smoking weed,
but like we got to do is burn down.
The whole system broke down.
It would be like when they found marlin
brando and apocalypse now and the
desert,
he's talking about the snail going
across the razor blade,
razor blade.
I feel like it's really right now with
everyone that's involved in it.
It's a.
It's a test of endurance.
Oh yeah.
Right.
It's who is going to last the longest.
Who's gonna?
KEep on fighting.
It's shaking.
You know,
we're having an earthquake and the
earthquake is going to fuck up.
All those shitty buildings.
All the ones without the strong
foundation.
They're gonna.
They're gonna be brecht,
and we're going to have to condemn them
and tear them down and start fresh and
see.
I don't like it.
I don't like how this has gone.
I would have hoped that we got a savior.
I would've hoped that someone stepped in
that was a really reasonable person,
but I don't think a reasonable person
even could get traction.
I think our system is so fucked up that
we almost might benefit from some crazy
ass hole coming in here and doing what
he's doing.
I don't think you'd get a normal person
who one wants to be president and then
gets propped up by all the people that
are already in empower.
You don't get that.
That person couldn't agree more.
Right?
It's like,
oh,
this person has baggage.
Everyone at that fucking point has to
have baggage,
which is one of the things about obama
is that he was so measured and you know,
wasn't vindictive and what I mean,
maybe behind the scenes you killed a few
people.
I mean,
when you say few people,
people will go,
well,
what about drones though?
Oh yeah,
I was exactly thinking that.
Yeah,
I mean he certainly is responsible for
that.
They killed something like 80 percent
civilians.
Was it 10 percent of entire populations?
I was like,
what?
I think that was the most recent
statistic finding innocent deaths by
drone,
by percentage.
I really think it was.
It's super high.
Scary high.
Even you saying that sentence,
it's horrifying,
but that statistic exists,
right?
It's like,
hey,
can we just google a horror?
Google,
google horrific things happening right
now,
just weDding parties,
just hellfire missiles on wedding.
That's the internet right now.
It's us,
everyone yelling about politics and
cats.
What do you got,
jamie?
Would you say the top one that popped up
with nearly 90 percent of people killed
in recent drone strikes were not the
target.
Fuck jesus.
But guys,
they fixed it.
They fixed it from them.
My fucking head hurts and on the
huffington post put this article out and
everyone was like,
you know what,
let's chill.
And then the world was happy.
My fucking head hurts when you read
things like that.
Yeah.
I mean we live in,
I mean things are a bit chaotic or are
chaotic now,
but we live in disneyland compared to
world and I think that's important for
people to remember for sure.
But the problem is those people that are
over there in non disney land,
they're just like you or are they just
kinda shitty?
Roll the dice.
That's what's fucked and that's what's
fucked up about this whole refugee
thing.
This idea that somehow or another,
if someone's a muslim,
you can keep them from coming into this
country.
Like,
man,
I know a lot of muslims and they're nice
people.
Like you can't,
like just because someone believes wacky
shit.
okay.
Whether they're mooneys or whether
they're mormons with.
I know some really nice mormons.
They're fucking great people.
If you said,
should you get rid of them?
I said,
no,
you don't listen to them.
You don't really get a planet when you
die.
You don't have to wear the magic
underwear,
But they're nice folks.
I know people that believe nutty shit.
One of my best friends believes that the
the fucking government is spraying
things out of the back of planes.
When you see those contracts in the sky,
he thinks it's like,
what does he call this strategic aerosol
injection leads?
It's an ssi program.
Like,
no,
it's not.
you know,
it's,
there's a lot of people that believe
some ridiculous shit and they need the
opportunity just like all of us do,
to have peace and prosperity and to have
the opportunities you take in more
information that may make you reconsider
your beliefs.
Yeah.
I feel like when it comes to the
immigration thing,
there's people on two fronts,
right?
There's one as far as general
immigration people coming through
legally from countries and then there's
also the refugee program,
right?
And so what I've seen is a lot of
arguments of,
okay,
so you're saying that you know,
these people are displaced,
they're having to go through all these
horrible things.
People are saYing,
why is that my problem is because
America is the land of dreams and we
should offer that because we're great.
Why should that?
And then once again,
not my argument,
but why is that taking precedent over
me?
Who's,
who's,
you know,
I went to college,
things haven't worked out.
My life's fucking in shambles.
I have yelling that I have white
privilege all the time and the fucking
seems like the world's more and more
against me every day.
Why?
If,
if and in their heads like all these
people are at risk.
Let me stop right there for that guy.
I got three words.
What's a fuck yourself?
And then form words,
suck it up.
Pussy jesus christ you.
Oh,
you can be.
We'll call you have white privilege.
You freaking out,
you're in America,
bitch.
If if things aren't going well,
work harder,
figuring it out,
you're a white guy in America,
you're so lucky you finding shit to
complain about,
but so everybody has their own hand that
they're dealt,
right,
and some people are in impoverished
fucking coal miner communities in West
Virginia and some people are born in
marin county with a silver spoon in
their mouth.
GraNted we are.
We're all aware of that,
but if you don't think that your
opportunities are far greater because
you live in american and are.
If you're a syrian refugee coming over
here,
wrapped up in a fucking tent,
you're crazy.
You're crazy.
And one of the things that makes this
place so fucking special is that it's
the land of opportunity.
As soon as you stop having it be the
land of opportunity,
you stopped taking in those new people.
You stopped giving those people that
opportunity and then you make this place
a different thing.
You make this place.
This is this secluded,
isolated.
You know,
put the fence up,
put the wall up.
Everybody in is in.
Everybody else could go fuck themselves.
that's not what it is,
that you're changing what it is.
This is the land of opportunity.
This is a country that was founded
entirely by immigrants who killed the
natives,
but that that's.
That's what we are.
You know,
there's.
There's certainly good and bad to all
forms of immigration and there's
certainly good and bad to cultural
integration.
Cultural integration is where things get
really problematic,
especially for women,
for women and women that have dealt with
all the horrific situations that have
happened in all these european countries
where muslims have come in and the
radical ones have wanted to enforce
their ideas,
the sharia law ideas on the women in the
area and they see women walking around
me,
skirts and all that stuff is a real
problem.
The Integration of cultural norms and
values into a western society that has
just a completely different idea of
what's acceptable and not acceptable.
That's going to take some time and if I
was in that area,
I get the fuck out of dodge.
I would not want to be around.
If there's a culture war going on,
what people are fighting and arguing
over ideas that may or may not include
your wife,
your daughter,
your mother,
that's too dangerous.
Then you'd have a lot of those same
people that I talk about saying,
well,
why the fuck should I have to move
because we're this thing.
you can't let that happen in America.
That's a different thing,
but that's the problem.
You cannot let that happen in America.
If you get people that are coming,
you have to have a no tolerance policy
to anyone that's giving anyone a hard
time over accepted values in America.
Like the way women are allowed to dress
or driving cars.
What if you come over from Saudi Arabia
and you want to kill all the women that
are driving cars?
You know like what if you would,
if you want to impart sharia law and on
women that are committing adultery or
doing any of the things that are just
really.
There's no law against a girl decided to
fuck 100 guys in America.
If a girl decides to rent out a
warehouse and go,
hey,
you know,
first a hundred guys get the fuck man,
come on in.
Like in another country,
like you can be put to death for that
and that there are women that are
arrested that are sexually assaulted.
Yes.
Like when you look at what sucks is it's
not like that was one story.
There's so many stories over the years
and it's fucking.
It's horrifying,
but so that's why I then argued because
even to the point that you're saying
there are people that are scared of
that,
but there has to be some sort of a zero
tolerance policy for subjecting other
people to your ideas and beliefs in that
way,
but it also,
every culture evolves.
Mean christians used to be a part of the
inquisition.
I mean that Was,
they were torturing people and they were
there getting people to confess to
horrific crimes and they never really
did.
They did all sorts of things to people
that were nonbelievers and that was a
normal part of life in some parts of the
world a long time ago.
Right.
We have to assume that that kind of
progress is not just isolated to
christians.
It's not just something that one belief
system can,
can sort of embodied that sort of
evolution,
that this can be something that we
experienced in a lot of different
mindsets,
a lot of different ideologies,
and then the opportunity to educate
those people in a place where they're
free might be the only way that's ever
going to change when the echo chamber of
the middle east where these people are
growing up in these and obviously you're
talking about places with very few
resources,
really dangerous environments for
everyone.
YOu know,
if you're living in these incredibly
impoverished middle eastern places where
these people were freeing.
I mean if you are fleeing,
I mean you've seen the videos of aleppo,
you've seen the stuff of the news.
I mean it's.
Anything's better than that.
Anything's better than being in a a
bombs zone where things are just going
off left and right and suicide bombings
and missiles and chaos and death and
isis throwing people off the roof for
being gay.
I mean,
it's just horrific.
So those people that are living in that,
it's almost like their life.
It can't get any worse.
Right?
They are in hell.
They literally in an apocalypse right
now.
If you look at a mel gibson movie look,
get any kind of crazy mad max movie.
How is that any different than Syria
right now?
I mean it's really not.
It's just we know that one of the
reasons why we don't consider this the
apocalypse right now because it's not
the apocalypse here in woodland hills,
right?
You know,
but it's the apocalypse in Syria,
it's the apocalypse and there's pockets
of the world where things are absolutely
horrific and those areas were scared.
Those areas going to come here and make
us the apocalypse to.
Yeah.
But I mean it goes back to the
disneyland thing where it is it
disneyland and where
were really pissed that some of the
rides are closed than where we're in
line and we feel like other people are
getting ahead,
but it's not.
It's not that it is not,
it doesn't compare.
But I have,
I have a bleeding heart in,
in,
in some capacity is when,
when you see those things and you're
like,
we have to help whoever we have to help,
but my goal is to always understand the
guy that doesn't want to have to fucking
move out of his neighborhood because all
these,
all these people came in and the culture
changed,
right?
It's just tAking into account his
mindset where you're.
I mean even you said,
all of a sudden you're worried about
your daughter,
your wife,
that there are people that have that
mindset.
And,
and I mean,
and we're human beings.
It's the easiest thing in the world to
create an us versus them argument,
especially if there's fear onto my
family.
I mean,
if you're anyone that's a,
you have,
you have fear for yourself,
but anytime all of a sudden you have a
family,
it's next level will also.
I tHink people were worried about people
coming over here and not integrating and
then coming over here and then they
start these communities where they all
use the same language and they all use
the same.
YOu know,
the same written language on their signs
and then they develop these like
chinatown titan neighborhoods.
Not disparaging chinatown in any way,
but that just as an example of ethnic
communities,
it's sort of stay isolated,
right?
Like there's places in chinatown where
you go and no one's speaking english,
they'll just running around speaking
chinese and they can't speak english,
but they figured out a way to integrate.
THere's,
there's also latino communities in this
country that are like,
that's similarly as well and I think
people are worried about that,
like that spreading and they say that
that has actually happened in parts of
paris and it's happened in parts of
Germany where these people have come
over from other countries as refugees
and they've established communities and
then they enforce their laws and that
was something that my low was going to
do.
He was going to do some sort oF a march
and he was going to do like some,
a gay march through,
I think it was Sweden.
I think it was going to go through like
the worst muslim neighborhoods and
Sweden,
but they just decided it was far too
sweet and trips so much promo on a
sweetened promo.
They're in denial.
They're like,
no,
we're fine.
Hey,
we haven't done anything.
And then right afTer they said that some
horrific outbreak took place by the way,
it's got a little violence going on
there and now that you didn't use to
have.
Right?
Right.
But this is growing pains.
Like if you take people from a violent
place and then you let them loose and
like there was this one horrific story
about this guy from Iraq that came over
some,
some refugee and he raped some boy in
Germany and his response where they
asked him why he did it was like I
hadn't seen my wife and six months and I
was having a sexual emergency.
Yeah.
SO it'll be like what?
Like there's things.
Actually,
I don't think it was from Iraq,
I think it was from Afghanistan,
but there's,
there's things that go on in other parts
of the world that become.
I don't want to say the norm,
but they do happen there.
Well that they don't happen.
That's where I think it's important that
in general,
people don't have the time where it's
important to,
to be as educated as possible because if
we're,
if we're basing things off of the way
things are generally becoming or it
seems like more and more.
Yes.
But if yOu're basing stuff off of
outliers,
um,
I think that's where,
that's where things are crazy.
Were you here?
Um,
you know,
someone that was here illegally,
they keep talking about the same story
over and over.
It was like,
it was a someone who are illegally.
There was a murder.
Right.
And it's like the same story and I want
to see,
I want to see the bigger picture because
yes,
that's fucking horrifying and a bubble.
But what's the,
what's the big thing?
If it leans more towards,
holy shit,
this is scary then.
Yeah.
But if you base something off of like
with guns,
right?
If you base something off of one
specific shooting,
that is like if you look at the body
count,
the guns involved specifically if it's
an outlier,
if it's.
If it's representative of a biGger
problem,
then if you really go after the bigger
if you actually want to have an effect,
it's not just superficial or that's not
just a big stance,
well,
we all want to be safe and we all want
our loved ones safe and so do they mean
that's what I think is really important
and when they don't anymore,
when,
when when people don't want to be safe
or they don't want their loved one safe,
then we have to figure out why.
Like what?
What'S going on that you're willing to
strap your kid full of dynamite and have
him walk into a mall and blow people up
like and now you think he's a holy
martyr.
I remember watching some documentary on
suicide bombings and they were raising
these children to be suicide bombings
and they had these pictures of these
kids,
these holy images of these children with
suicide vests on,
on the wall that had already committed
suicide.
And there was a sign in islamic that
said,
uh,
today's actually islamic's not a
language.
When I talked to her mom,
I was like,
oh yeah,
go with it.
Yeah.
Well in arabic,
excuse me.
But it said today's children are
tomorrow's holy martyrs.
And that was on the wall and they were
interviewing these people and trying to
wrap their head around this and make
sense of it.
You know,
when you've got situations like that,
everyone should be scared because then
people embrace their ideology to the
point where they're willing to let their
own babies blow themselves up in k so
you've got a real problem there and
that,
that is as much of a problem as any kind
of cult,
any kind of mind control,
any kind of.
And if,
if that's happening over here,
yeah,
yeah.
That needs to be taken into
consideration.
But how many people are doing that?
What is the percentage?
how many people aren't doing that?
How many people are productive,
kind,
reasonable people that are stuck in a
really shitty place.
And isn't that supposed to be what
America is about?
So you can't just say there's a small
percentage of people that are doing
horrific shit,
so now we can't let anybody that looks
like them in as that gets crazy and that
isolates us from the whole rest of the
world too.
But it ain't easy man and it's not an
easy problem to solve and I'm certainly
not the fucking guy to do it.
right.
Ditto.
Yeah.
Because because the argument
automatically becomes,
but what if my family right and then
secure people.
How do you make things secure?
I don't know.
Good question.
Well,
there's a screen.
That thing is saying no,
there's no such thing as safety before
they were safety.
Right.
But you can make things more safe.
You can make things somewhat safe.
But I mean it,
it's a dark thing to think about.
But before there were even more of these
shootings that happened.
you look at why do you have to.
Why do you have to blow up a plane or
why do you have to crash a plane if you
can just get the people in line,
right?
If you go to a mall,
why?
There are people that are just,
they're all soft targets everywhere.
no one's ever going to be fully safe
unless it's under some crazy,
crazy,
crazy like big brother control and I
don't want that either because there'll
be consequences for going against big
brother.
So for me,
when I,
when I talk about these things,
it's just it's a we're fucked,
but in what way are we going to be
fucked situation and I know that can be
a dark.
I know,
but it is dark.
It's just,
it's disappointing there.
There's no such thing as ultimate
safety,
right?
I think I understand the argument of gun
free zones,
great targets.
Their targets everywhere.
Well,
here's the real question.
How do you make the rest of the world?
Like if you,
if you were some sort of a really
benevolent person who is just looking to
do the best,
the best job of managing this world and
making all the places that are in
disarray and these horrific war zones
and bring them up.
How do you.
How do you ever do that?
Like how do you ever even the world out?
No,
it's ever
we need.
We need aliens to come to,
to come and get it.
That's the only time humanity works out
is when we have a common enemy.
But the problem is we're always our own
common enemy,
but I will.
But is that inevitable?
I mean,
at one point in time,
people were way worse,
right?
At one point in time there was like,
one of the things that really freaked me
out was when they started finding all
these scraping marks on the inside of a
neanderthal heads that indicated that
people were eating the neanderthal
brains.
And I was like,
oh,
jesus.
Like,
and then there was an article recently
about cannibalism,
about how frequent cannibalism occurred
back in the day.
And it was,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
obviously that's not going on anymore.
Right?
Okay.
Is that the bar far less cannibalism
than ever before?
That's the bar.
We're fucked.
We're like,
we're not eating each other.
I mean,
say what you will.
We're not eating each other.
Well,
it used to be that you couldn't just
show up in a new town,
right?
You couldn't just pull your boat up in,
into,
uh,
some doc somewhere.
And get out and do some tourists
shopping because if you pulled your boat
up,
that meant you were probably a bunch of
rapists and murderers from some other
place.
You're comIng over with swords and bows
and arrows and shooting everybody and
killing them.
Taking all the gold.
Well,
that's not the case anymore,
so things are much more reasonable in
terms of foreign travel,
in terms of international relations.
Things are much more reasonable to think
that if it continues to go in that
direction,
we'll we'll have a better world for our
grandchIldren and our great
grandchildren,
but what steps have to be taken to make
sure that the rest of the world's
horrific conditions
don't spill over to America?
Well isn't one of the best ways to take
those people out of those horrific
conditions and introduce them to this
beautiful free concept is concept of
self,
government.
This,
this,
this unique place where there isn't a
caste system where you can.
If yOu play your cards right and you,
you're fortunate and you get the right
brakes and putting the right amount of
work,
you literally can go from being a poor
person to being a very wealthy person.
You can go from being unsuccessful witH
no,
no job and no hope to being very
successful and happy.
It's.
It's possible here and it's one of the
few places in the world when you can
build yourself up like that and I think
that is an amazing opportunity that
probably didn't exist in history.
I,
I think I'm too much of a cynic to think
that the idea of all of us coming
together on a positive idea will bring
us altogether.
I 100 percent think it has to be a bad
thing that unites us meteor impact or
some shit.
Meteor impact fake fake that aLiens are
coming.
So we all have to come together to make
everyone fake them.
Well,
aliens,
I want to kill us in like the next 10
years rather than at some point in the
eventual time.
I don't think
the word 10 years is not good because
people are good.
We'll deal with it.
None at all.
They'll just go fucking crazy though.
The bottom line is,
bro,
when the aliens get here,
they're going to fucking kill us all.
you're raping while you can.
I think.
I think they're going to be on my side.
They're going to call you an alien
apologist.
They'd be like,
oh,
he's an alien apologist.
He doesn't get joe rogan disconnected
from the people.
Yeah,
man.
He's up there and his fucking house with
a tv and he doesn't know.
He doesn't give a shit about those
aliens.
He said he did qa drive where he wants
to go to duke.
Who is jealous of the internet
connection because it was in africa.
Live in a grass hut.
Don't worry.
Zuckerberg is fixing it.
Has he?
Supposedly right?
Didn't one of those statement.
Bill gates.
It blew up right there where they're
spending a ton of money on a satellite.
It was one of the space that really.
That blew up.
Yeah.
There was supposed to be an nc that the
one big one that recently blew up was to
provide satellite internet access to
impoverished parts of africa.
Yeah,
man,
I don't know.
I think,
I think the more connected that it is,
it's a good thing,
but yeah,
it has to be a bad thing.
That has to be a bad thing that unites
us of where we become the we or the us
versus them,
the other cars,
but the problem is there is whether it
be nationalism or religion or fucking
anything,
there's so many things that within our
own creative creating us an easy us
versus them mentality and I mean I'm a
personal believer in that eventually
we're just gonna kill it,
kill ourselves.
That's what you think.
Yeah.
God damn philly,
I think it's just going to happen.
I don't want it to happen.
Let's,
let's,
let's hurry things up.
It's safer now than it's ever been
before.
Statistically speaking,
today's the safest time ever to be
alive.
I'm talking about on a grand scale.
I'm not talking as a grand scale.
when you talk about statistically
speaking,
that's the grand scale.
I'm talking about like the next big
thing to happen as far as whether it be
all out war,
not,
not.
The things that are happening are
happening in our streets right now.
God damn doom and gloom.
I'm planning for 20,
24.
It's going to be make birth rate again.
That's going to be mega new.
Um,
how old are you?
I'm 31.
So you were young when nine slash 11
happened?
Yes,
I was in.
I was in my classroom and they like
wheeled in the tv.
Oh wow.
What,
what grade were,
do you remember?
I want to say I was in middle.
No,
I think it might have been my first year
of high school.
I,
I moved around.
I'm trying to think.
I'm having a hard time placing it,
but I remember I was in class.
I for my memory at the product's problem
with memory is like,
I feel like you've made me slightly
change it 100 percent,
but from my understanding or my memory,
uh,
they wield the tv and um,
it was after the first tower got hit and
then I'm pretty sure we watched the
second tower get hit live.
I think that's what happened.
Wow.
And that was just in my head.
It was a mix of horror a to then also
them because they cut to a certain shots
because they're the shots that you
remember if people running away from the
debris,
but then there was also shots with
people just looking at it and then some
people just like walking at a steady
pace before the second one hit.
And I was like,
wow,
like nothing for a second.
When I looked at the people that were
there before the,
You saw like the people running in to
help people.
I thought nothing can destroy us.
Like that was,
that was kind of my mindset of this
horrible thing just happened and it was
before the second one hit.
So it was like,
what's,
what's happening?
Um,
but I mean,
I think that's a good example too.
I don't want that to ever happen again.
Uh,
in a,
in a smaller,
a big scale.
But do you remember how united everyone
was?
that's why I brought it up.
Yeah,
it was,
it was.
The problem is we became,
we somehow took that situation and then
made everything horrible.
Um,
but,
but it waS an us,
like we,
there was a,
there was a united us,
it was,
it was american,
but it wasn't just the united us,
it was also the rest of the world was
sympathetic to our plight.
And there was a headline and some paper
in paris that said,
we're all americans today that would
never happen now.
Not in a million years.
Have the same exact thing happened.
Would it be they would be like,
you deserve it.
Why are you in,
why you in Afghanistan?
It wouldn't,
it wouldn't be.
We're all americans because back then we
had invaded Iraq.
We hadn't invaded Afghanistan and it
was,
there was so much more sympathy just 16
years ago.
Well,
even closer to.
I mean,
when charlie hebdo,
right,
they got hit.
It was just sweet charlie.
Now when something happens,
it's like,
well,
look at what's happening there.
We want more,
we want that here.
Right?
so it's,
there's,
there's definitely a death metal thing
where they've gone down all those people
that concert or some paris,
leon France,
the,
uh,
the truck driver that drove over.
Everybody pull.
Yeah.
And
I mean,
there's a lot less of.
We are right,
it's more of look what's happening and
it's more,
it's definitely more fear based rather
than if we're just united and we stand
against this,
there still is that.
It's just not as big.
Well,
I was in New York right after September
11th.
It wasn't very long afterwards.
And I remember it was amazing how
friendly everybody was.
It was just a different feel.
People Were shook and their response in
recovery to that was people were smarter
and smarter,
kinder and they were smiling more and
it's just,
it was a different.
It was a different feel.
There was more comradery and massive,
massive respect to first responders.
Yes,
massive respect to police and fire
department.
They had just,
there was a different feeling and how
the people felt about them instead of
being the oppressors,
they became the saviors and it not
fireman.
I mean,
nobody ever thinks of the firemen is the
oppressors.
Firemen.
Well,
there's was a thing in the riots after
the riots in la where they were
attacking fireman like they were.
Yeah.
it was horrible.
There was shooting at him.
It was,
um,
a thing where people just decided that
the man,
whoever the man is needed to go down,
whether it was fire department or police
and they were shooting at cops and
that's insanity.
They were burning buildings down that
had nothing to do with the riots.
And I'm sure you saw there was a,
um,
a piece on these korean business owners
in Korea town.
They were invaded during the riots
because,
you know,
they're not the best,
uh,
the proximity to where all the south
central shit was going down post rodney
king and these people were on the
rooftops just trying to defend their
stores and trying to,
you know,
stop looters from taking away everything
they earned and everything they worked
for their whole lives.
And you know,
those moments when things get chaotic,
they do open up the door for people to
reconsider how fortunate we are when
things aren't chaotic.
Right?
It's,
I think that's a very unfortunate thing
that we only open up our,
our,
our open ourselves up after something
horrible.
Um,
and because I think that we see horrible
thing after a horrible thing,
we slowly get further and further away
from being able to unite just because
it's at least in our 24 slash seven news
cycle it seems like if that's just the
world we live in,
right?
It's just like they're scary shit man.
Hopefully we can keep that away from us.
And again,
it goes back to what we're talking about
really early on.
I just honestly think we're taking in
too much data,
like your life in my life should really
revolve around the people that were in
contact with the people that we
communicate with and our immediate
surroundings and our immediate
surroundings.
We both work in the same area.
It's really pleasant.
It's really fine.
And the folks we run into for the most
part,
like 99 point nine percent of them are
very pleasant and hi,
how you doing?
What's up?
How are you?
Everything's good,
you know?
And that's really how we're supposed to
be thinking about the world.
This is,
this is our world.
But now our world is extended to include
Pakistan and North Korea.
And what is happening here and what's
happening there?
Did you hear that?
King john owns half brother was with
some toxic
painters.
Like fuck man,
why don't have to think about that guy.
I don't know.
That guy is too many people.
There's too much.
And that can really give you this really
bizarre,
twisted sense of the state of the world
that the.
If you just go out now and look at like
bill hicks used to have a joke about
that,
about watching cnn and it was all about.
Because a jane fonda wouldn't fuck ted
turner.
This is back when you'd go outside and
uh,
you know,
they'd be like today on the news aids,
death,
murder,
pitbulls,
guns,
stabbings,
and you go outside hear birds chirping
or where the fuck is all this happening?
I forget
what I was listening to,
but it was,
it was,
it was a comparison to when people are
thinking about the world,
when they're thinking about the country,
all of that is usually far,
far different when they talk about their
local community.
Because our local community were like,
oh,
things are for them.
A lot of people think things are good.
Obviously there are places where bad
shit's happening,
but when we look at our own community,
we're like,
that's great and I do think that's a
place where we start,
right?
Make me for sure.
May make the local good and try and
expand from there because yeah,
when,
when when you look out and you,
you look at it specifically like chicago
as the state of the United States,
that's not what it is.
It's scary.
They're sitting side of chicago was
actually really nice.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
so yeah,
once again you have to look at specific
places,
but like when trump is saying when
donald trump's talking about chicago,
this is stuff that I've been talking to
my show like two years.
I had segments almost every monday where
it was like this is how many people died
in chicago and it's crazy numbers,
but then you look,
you look close and you're just like,
oh,
things are good.
And I think that's where everyone needs
to start,
start locally and then kind of expand
from there to get that local to somehow
or another make its way into chicago.
Yeah.
Because most people,
you just,
you have your,
your small little group.
You're,
you're in a great position where I get
to talk to hundreds of thousands,
millions of people.
Same for me.
Um,
and,
and we're in this exceptional,
amazing position that of I feel like I'm
so scared to do the wrong thing,
but how were you scared to do the wrong?
I don't want to mislead people.
That's what I mean in the sense of like
when I do my show,
it's just like I have a whole team for
full production and stuff like that.
But I'm,
I'm researching it because it's my name
on the line and I want to really in the
past year and a half just focusing like
how do we get to the truth?
I'm not infallible.
They're going to be mistakes and stuff
along the way.
But how can I try and I guess I got 10
minutes to 20 minutes of someone's life.
Right?
And that's,
that's hUge,
especially with how much information
people are getting and people hold on to
shit that they see in a fucking two
second glimmer of a tweet.
So I want to make sure that I'm trying
in that way to make my community,
which happens to be a little larger than
your everyday joe.
Good.
Like a good,
good,
smart place where we don't have to
agree,
but we're working on iT.
Great.
You're doing the right thing,
man.
It's very admirable.
I,
you know,
I think what we're talking about with
chicago,
Syria and all these other things too,
just when you're dealIng with the data
from 7 billion people and that is
unfathomable.
It's impossible.
It's impossible to handle.
And so that's why take a look then look
like you're saying around you and start
from there.
Yeah.
Because otherwise you're going to at
some point and just be completely wrong
and I think it's probably a good idea
for all of us.
You and I included to filter out some of
the data that we're taking in.
There's just too much at this point in
time.
You can just be inundated with horrific
news all day long if you so choose to.
Oh yeah.
You know,
and there those rabbIt holes you can.
Sometimes it's just there,
Alex Jones,
until your fucking head explodes.
I mean you really could.
You can go down to all the dark pizza
gate rabbit holes until you can't take
it anymore.
It's just you.
You can find the worst parts of the
world,
the worst pockets of terrorism,
the worst,
and you just absorb yourself in that
data and then you wIll be convinced
that's the life that is the world,
but I think that's why people have to
fight a good fight right now to be like,
oh,
we're heroes.
But I think that's why you have to have
people that throw themselves out there
that are going to get steamrolled by
people that oppose on that specific day,
that viewpoint,
but you have to have those people
because otherwise the just the people
that have that time that want to see the
world just fucking implode.
Right?
They're the people that have a lot of
people that have that time,
so we have to,
I think be dedicated to have a
conversation and this is the last thing
I want to ask you about,
and this might come off as being silly,
but I think there might be some validity
to it.
Do you think that this ability that you
have and and I have and all the people
that come on this podcast or any podcast
have this new ability to express ideas
and communicate.
Do you think that that is having an
effect on the way people view the world
and that this open form of communication
where you know,
you and I with I,
I've never been trained in the media.
Have you Trained as an emt but he told
you how to do this right now,
but you and I to normal people,
we can communicate to millions of people
having this conversation and then
millions of people will talk to their
friends and express their own opinions.
Whether they agree,
disagree,
or maybe have some other things to add
to it.
They express that to their friends at
work and their friends you know at home
and these dialogues take on a life of
their own and they they they these ideas
that we're expressing and that other
people expressing at work or at play
there,
they're more potent now and they spread
faster now than they ever have before
and I think there's an evolution of
ideas that's taking place now.
Good and bad.
That's where all the whIte privilege
shit comes from and all the,
all the gender politics and all the
weirdness,
all of it comes from these turbo charged
ideas,
these nuclear ideas now where ideas
spread to the point where words become
taboo and use the wrong gender pronoun
when you're talking about a trans person
and you're the worst human ever and all
these new things that are existing and I
think these new things are because
dialogue and information is just.
It has a different weight to it now.
It's almost like the gravity has shifted
on it.
I think a lot of the reason why we have
our positions and other people do it is
because it is that it is a,
it is a dialogue.
It is in a weird way and extended
friend,
group friends talking about things.
That's where people have,
I think,
the best conversations as far as where
we grow,
right?
If mean they constantly come out with
numbers of the trust in media,
right?
Just like they have an agenda,
but if it's just people talking,
right,
this guy's talking,
um,
that you don't feel like joe's got this
agenda that he wants to just shoved down
everyone's throat or they're gonna be
people that say that.
But I think that's good.
It is.
There's always going to be shit that
then becomes this like confirmation
bias.
I only deal with the friends that
confirm what I think,
but I think,
I think it's a very good thing.
It's where it's the more human way to,
to take in information and,
and form an opinion and,
and grow from it.
I think
that opinion's going to shift to and
move around.
It does.
Because when people look back and
they're like,
this person flip flop,
that person fucking grew.
hopefully.
I mean,
iT could be completely calculated it on
pandora and blah blah
data or change who they are.
I mean,
you,
you
know,
flip flopping things so silly.
It's like,
oh,
this person has a yes,
hopefully,
hopefully you can have a different
opinion that you're not locked into
something.
And so that's,
I think that everyone needs to focus on
it with like the not the,
not ever going to school for this sort
of thing.
I've never taken a journalism class.
I've talked about it in a video.
Uh,
I focus on,
I call like the liquor method,
right?
I listened,
I questioned,
I research and I refute right.
So I take in as many sources as I can,
whether it be the huffington post and
cnn or fox news,
breitbart,
the donald,
anything I want to see where everyone's
coming from,
right?
Then I start throwing out questions,
you know,
where,
where does this come from?
What do they say?
Go down that rabbit hole with research
and then I'm armed with information.
That's why I think whether you have a
milo or you have fucking anybody let
people talk so you can learn because
information's ammo,
right?
Information,
something that you can take in,
understand,
but if it's a flawed argument,
even if it's opinion based,
if it's a flawed argument,
then you can use it and then,
and maybe it's not a flawed argument,
you fucking learn something,
right?
Maybe.
Maybe you thought you were right,
you were wrong.
That's cool.
That's fine.
Like,
flip flop,
have a different opinion.
Uh,
so I'm,
I'm for it all day.
I think you got to grow.
I think there are people that wake up in
the morning,
a fucking burn the world,
but I don't,
I refuse to believe that that's the
majority.
And,
and I'm going to start trying to deal
with people I think that are sensible
that at the very least think they're
sensible.
Weed ouT.
The ones really aren't once
tested and just fucking go.
I'm a hundred percent with you.
And I really liked what you're doing
because I think you're a very reasonable
guy.
I think you're very well thought out and
when you consider things like the most
recent milo video you're being,
you're being very fair and I think the
world needs more of that reasonable and
fair.
Thank you phil.
Thank you sir.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being reasonable and fair.
That's it for the week.
You motherfuckers.
Thanks for tuning in.
I love you guys.
See you next week.
Bye.